monsieur le Président du Sénat monsieur
le Président de la MF cher Jacques
pélissa qui est en quelque sorte le père
de la commune nouvelle si je puis dire
Mesdames et Messieurs les mères Mesdames
et Messieurs les élus je suis très
honorée président l'archet que vous ayez
accepté de manière spontanée avec
beaucoup de conviction d'apporter votre
haut patronage à cette matinée qui nous
donne le plaisir
de réfléchir ensemble à MF et Sénat sur
cette commune nouvelle qui est je crois
dans notre pays ce que j'appelle une
pépite législative car il n'y a pas
d'autres exemples de dispositif mis à la
disposition des élus qui souhaitent s'en
emparer pour construire leur avenir et
le président du Sénat a conduit voilà
deux ans un groupe de travail très
écuminique au Sénat pour
réfléchir à la meilleure manière
d'organiser notre territoire et il a
ainsi appelé les 50 propositions du
Sénat des propositions en faveur des
libertés locales et je crois que la
commune nouvelle et l'examen de cette
liberté locale dans les élus peuvent se
saisir et je suis heureuse président
l'archet de vous laisser ou de vous
permettre ou de vous accueillir pour
ouvrir cette demi-journée de réflexion
merci président
je donne tout de suite la parole à
Monsieur le président Gérard Larcher
madame la présidente de la délégation
c'est d'intervient le collectivité
territoriale et à la décentralisation
chère Françoise Gatel monsieur le
Président de l'Association des maires de
France chère David Lisnard cher Jacques
pélissarq nous retrouvons avec très très
grand plaisir
ce matin
je voudrais saluer Philippe Chalopin
avec qui nous avons déjà beaucoup
échangé avec son expérience de bouger en
Anjou et bien sûr saluer tous mes
collègues et particulièrement Agnès
canaillé qui a été rapporteur de ce
texte ici et Mesdames et Messieurs les
maires et présidents d'intercommunalité
qui est ici présent et tous les
collègues sénateurs vous dire et c'est
sincère
mon plaisir de vous accueillir ce matin
au Sénat pour cette rencontre nationale
des élus des communes nouvelles à
l'initiative conjointe de Françoise
Gatel et de David Lisnard
oui cher Françoise guettel merci pour
cette initiative
la commune nouvelle à une place
particulière dans votre cœur tout le
monde le sait vous êtes aussi à
l'origine de la proposition de loi du
premier août 2019 qui vise et adapter
l'organisation des communes nouvelles à
la diversité des territoires chers
qui comprise aujourd'hui cette séance de
travail en tant que président de
l'Association des maires de France le
Sénat et la maison des mers
naturellement et votre maison et je
salue l'implication de votre association
dans cette rencontre je crois que vous
diffuserez aujourd'hui en avant-première
si mon service de renseignement est au
point le panorama des communes nouvelles
vous avez fait le choix
d'intitulé cette rencontre comme une
nouvelle pour un nouveau souffle vous
posez d'emblée la question d'un nouvel
élan à donner au mouvement de création
que notre pays connaît depuis 10 ans
avec environ 2600 communes regroupées en
près de 800 communes nouvelles je crois
que c'est même très exactement 787
c'est un chiffre qui aujourd'hui parait
stabilisé et un constat s'impose celui
d'une concentration sur une aire
géographique plutôt au quart nord-ouest
de notre pays
une quinzaine de départements
concentrale celle plus de la moitié de
ses créations
le mouvement des communes nouvelles
avait été qualifié
de révolution silencieuse
c'était cher Françoise Gatel dans un
rapport d'information 2016
que vous aviez rendu avec Christian
madame alors sénateur de la Somme
nous pouvons effectivement parler d'une
révolution puisque ce sont près de 2
millions 500 000 nos compatriotes qui
ont été concernés par le choix effectué
par leurs élus de se regrouper en
commune nouvelle
révolution silencieuse un mouvement
douceur un peu antinomique de parler de
révolution
silencieuse et de mouvement en douceur
c'est en effet cette révolution
silencieuse qui enclenché la loi de
réforme des collectivités locales du 16
décembre
2010 en instant la possibilité pour
plusieurs communes de se regrouper au
sein d'une commune nouvelle sergette
pélissa il s'agissait alors de donner
aux élus locaux la possibilité de
constituer ou de consolider de
véritables pôles de vie ruraux ou urbain
doté de leur projet tout en conservant
leur identité il s'agissait aussi de
donner la possibilité de réinsuffler de
la proximité dans certaines des plus
grandes intercommunalités
il s'agissait d'ouvrir une possibilité
et non d'imposer
c'est essentiel au moment de la
rédaction c'est essentiel pour moi et je
crois monsieur le Président que c'est
essentiel aussi par l'Association des
maires de France aujourd'hui
c'est en cela que cette loi a été
verteuse elle repose sur le libre choix
des élus locaux sur un modèle de
développement différencié adapté à
chaque territoire
cette condition de liberté me paraît
vraiment essentiel je le répète
l'AMF a fait de longues dates le choix
d'accompagner le mouvement des communes
nouvelles mais elle a toujours œuvré
pour que cette création demeure une
démarche libre volontaire des élus
municipaux en lien je n'ai pas encore
prononcé ce mot avec leur population je
vois que là où ça n'a pas été fait en
lien avec les populations il y a parfois
eu des difficultés et parfois de très
grosses difficultés voir des échecs j'en
ai connu dans mon propre département
cette double condition de liberté de
choix des élus locaux et d'association
des habitants à la décision me paraît
déterminante parce que les Français
qu'ils soient habitants de longue
dateaux récemment installés se
définissent d'abord par leur identité
communale
c'est en la commune que s'accorde la
République c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs la
possibilité de conserver des maires
déléguées dans les communes historiques
me paraît importante
vous allez revenir ce matin sur les
expériences concrètes de constitution
d'une commune nouvelle permettant
d'identifier les conditions de réussite
ce travail est souvent difficile
notamment sur les questions
d'harmonisation fiscale
il faut peut-être adapter le processus
de création des communes nouvelles au
contexte actuel avec les tensions que
nous connaissons sur les ressources
financières locales
je sais que la question des relations
avec les autres niveaux de collectivité
et l'État sera aussi posé lors de vos
tableaux
je vais donc vous souhaiter une
excellente matinée de travail vos
témoignages et vos préconisations nous
intéressent
notre assemblée sera naturellement
attentive à vos propositions
elles seront le reflet de toute la
diversité de nos territoires que vous
représentez aujourd'hui
elles doivent nous guider vers plus de
différenciation toujours plus de
pragmatisme et d'adaptabilité dans les
politiques que nous contribuons à
élaborer
Françoise gatelle évoquait il y a un
instant les 50 propositions le plein
exercice et libertés locales
j'installerai la semaine prochaine très
exactement le 5 octobre au Sénat le
groupe de travail pluraliste et je
reprends la formule Françoise Gatel et
ecuménique que je prédire présiderai et
dont Françoise Gatel sera d'ailleurs un
des co- rapporteur
ce sera l'occasion d'examiner ce sont
devenus ces 50 propositions certaines
ont trouvé une traduction législative
notamment lors de 3DS pour assouplir
entre autres le fonctionnement de
l'intercommunalité mais pas que nous
devons aller plus loin aujourd'hui la
décentralisation me paraît le principal
remède à la crise de confiance que nous
vivons qui se traduit d'ailleurs par
l'abstention élection après élection et
comme une nouvelle offre précisément une
réponse différenciée à des
problématiques locales elles permettent
de conserver un échelon proximité tout
en mutualisant les compétences et les
projets le réussite repose également sur
le principe d'une concertation avec les
populations et la recherche d'un large
consensus
il reviendrait réfléchir à la portée de
ce modèle toujours sur le principe de la
liberté de choix et de nous interroger
sur les aménagements à apporter c'est
donc pas un rendez-vous lointain puisque
nous aurons un rapport d'étape à la fin
de l'année et que nous conclurons de
travaux au moment où le printemps
pointera son nez c'est dire que nous
n'aurons pas dans ce qui est annoncé
comme la troisième grande annonce une
grande loi de décentralisation et bien
nous verrons mais nous serons prêts et
nous jouerons pleinement notre rôle très
bonne journée de travail merci
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président du Sénat je
vais appeler maintenant David Lisnard
maire de Cannes et président de
l'Association des maires de France et
des présidents d'intercommunalité qui va
poursuivre ses discours d'introduction
merci merci monsieur le Président de cet
accueil de votre présence
de ces mots
de votre philosophie de l'action locale
et de faire du Sénat plus que jamais la
Grande Chambre des communes de France
vous le démontrez à chaque étape de nos
relations avec lesécutif à chaque
exigence du travail législatif les
communes l'AMF association
représentative de toutes les communes de
France
urbaine rurales plus grande association
de communes rurales de France puisque
nous sommes tous adhérents de l'AMF et
bien ont ici leur maison au Sénat pour
faire progresser le pays autour de cette
problématique essentielle qui est celle
de la performance publique et du sens de
l'appartenance à une communauté de
destin
c'est un grand honneur que nous avons
avec Françoise Gatel d'être accueilli
dans cette maison que connaît bien
Françoise et
Françoise à laquelle je veux rendre
hommage parce que
dès que j'ai eu la charge et la chance
d'être choisie par mes pères pour
présider l'Association des maires de
France tout de suite avec beaucoup de
précision d'intelligence de pubnacité
elle a su m'accompagner et Françoise
Gatel est une ardente combattante de la
cause des communes
de la responsabilité des communes de la
modernité que représente les communes
échelons de responsabilité donc de
liberté à condition qu'on nous laisse
travailler merci Françoise de porter ce
combat de porter cette énergie
inlassablement qui est celle d'une
certaine idée de la France que nous
partageons ici au-delà d'ailleurs de nos
sentiments d'appartenance partisan
j'ai plaisir bien sûr avec une certaine
émotion comme à chaque fois à saluer
Jacques Pelissard
car
c'est lui le coupable
c'est lui le il a une double une double
responsabilité c'est celle que je sois
aujourd'hui à ce pupitre puisque c'est
Jacques Pélissard qui le premier m'a
fait confiance dans la vie publique et
m'a permis d'avoir confiance en moi et
m'a fait partager sa passion pour la
commune et l'AMF et j'ai eu le privilège
et de la chance d'être son directeur de
cabinet tout cela ne nous rajeunit pas
mais on garde cette énergie en nous
cette nouvelle énergie oser
et Jacques Pélissard à la deuxième
responsabilité d'avoir été un fervent
partisan mais plus que partisan d'avoir
été Françoise et tout à l'heure le père
des communes nouvelles de cette
révolution silencieuse avec comme
toujours chez Jacques non pas la volonté
de se mettre dans la lumière mais le
souci de la précision la précision
sémantique au service de l'action et la
République
s'enorgueille et doit savoir reconnaître
le mérite de personnalité comme Jacques
Pélissard qui ne sont pas des praticiens
du coup politicien mais qui sont des
fabricants de l'intérêt général
[Applaudissements]
salut bien sûr tous les sénateurs ici
présents c'est toujours très
impressionnant que d'être dans cette
chambre haute merci à vous de votre
action permanente à nos côtés la
relation sénateur-mère sont une relation
d'amour et d'intérêt et c'est finalement
les deux conjugués qui font les mariages
les plus solides l'histoire nous
l'apprend qu'elle soit collective ou
individuelle
vous me permettrez de souligner saluer
aussi le travail important de Philippe
Chalopin présent parmi nous le maire de
baugé-en-anjou dans le Maine-et-Loire et
qui est lui aussi accompagne avec
beaucoup de passion de précision et
d'implication les communes nouvelles et
de saluer Paul Carrère et de tous ceux
qui d'ailleurs sont en visio aujourd'hui
et participent à notre journée et à
notre rencontre de même que Jean-Marc
Vasse et bien sûr tous les mers ici
présents y compris président
d'associations départementales de maire
ils sont au premier rang ils m'observent
et note donc je vais faire attention à
ne pas être trop long pour éviter de
dire trop de bêtises
vous l'avez dit monsieur le Président
Françoise a dit aussi quand on parle de
révolution silencieuse c'est peut-être
un oxymore mais en tout cas c'est une
réalité et pourquoi est-ce une
révolution parce que la commune nouvelle
est une exception dans le paysage de
l'évolution institutionnelle partant
d'un principe dont nous sommes les
ardents partisans je salue quand je dis
nous c'est la MF Monsieur le Directeur
Général Éric Verlhac la société mère de
France le sol les ardents partisans
depuis 1907
enfin pour ceux qui les plus anciens
d'entre vous mais depuis 1907 et que un
peu d'insolence et que l'AMF est a été
inventée pour défendre les libertés
locales
selon un principe que l'on doit
absolument
redécouvrir qui a valeur
constitutionnelle qui est le principe de
subsidiarité le principe de subsidiarité
on l'utilise ce terme parfois à tort en
tout cas on n'utilise pas assez mais la
réalité du principearité est une réalité
très simple le principe solidarité n'est
pas un principe technocratique ce n'est
pas une invention européenne c'est une
invention du tommyme de la démocratie
chrétienne qui consiste à dire que
chaque individu doit chercher à être
responsable de son destin et qu'ensuite
chaque lorsqu'on passe de l'individu à
l'action collective chaque collectivité
doit essayer elle-même de régler ses
problèmes de porter une ambition et puis
progressivement de mutualiser ce qui
doit être mutualisé à l'échelon
supérieur cette approche totalement
différente de l'approche centralisée
bureaucratisé vertical on dirait en
anglais au Top Down c'est une approche
buttem up quelques anglicisme ça fait
toujours bien dans un discours c'est une
approche ascendante c'est ça la
subsidiarité la subsidarité en fait
c'est tout simplement le terme compliqué
pour dire que ce qui fonctionne c'est la
responsabilité et qui n'existe pas de
responsabilité sans liberté d'action et
que tout ce qui entrave la liberté donc
la responsabilité par des schémas
directeurs par des prélèvements par la
non indexation des dotations c'est à
dire par la réalité de prélèvement
financiers de l'État sur nos capacités
d'action
et bien tout ce qui entrave nos
capacités juridico administratives et le
capacité financières d'action se fait au
détriment de l'intérêt général ce fait
au détriment de la performance publique
la commune nouvelle c'est tout le
contraire c'est le fait de dire plutôt
que d'avoir de nous voir imposer un
schéma technocratique partant d'une
croyance
erronée que les grands ensembles sont
toujours plus pertinents que les
échanges proximité ça peut être vrai
c'est souvent faux dans l'entreprise
comme dans le secteur public vient de
dire que ce qui fonctionne c'est ce qui
correspond à une volonté à une volonté
du terrain
de mutualiser sans s'éloigner
c'est à dire de faire des économies
d'échelle sans éloigner la décision du
terrain c'est cela qui a guidé je parle
sous le contrôle de ces géniteurs là
l'émergence et l'invention de la commune
nouvelle alors cette philosophie là nous
devons absolument la promouvoir la
défendre dans toutes les façons
d'aborder l'organisation des pouvoirs
publics oui la solution monsieur le
Président elle est dans la
décentralisation elle est dans la
fusillarité parce qu'elle est dans la
liberté et la responsabilité locale
on a coutume encore de dire lorsque on
va sur un plateau nous dit les 36000
communes de France et je rectifie non
les
34955 communes de France je dis bon
chiffre non oui c'est ça c'est bon 34955
comme Île-de-France et ce qui a été
réussi par une volonté conjuguée des
maires de France et des législateurs et
notamment au Sénat et bien a permis
cette révolution silencieuse de
regroupement de communes sans être dans
la contrainte en étant dans le choix
alors évidemment rien n'est parfait vous
l'avez dit monsieur le Président a des
communes nouvelles qui fonctionne moins
bien que d'autres il y a des tensions il
y a parfois ce qui relève de tout
simplement de la nature humaine qui ne
rêve pas de l'organisation
administrative mais comme dans nos
communes nous avons aussi parfois des
conflits mais en toute hypothèse la
philosophie de la commune nouvelle est
bonne parce que les résultats sont là
parce qu'elle a permis de retrouver ou
de catalyser de stimuler une identité
locale qui soit conforme aux racines et
à l'image et à l'histoire de ce terroir
mais qui se projette dans le 21e siècle
donc nous devons nous avons un rôle
capital pour stimuler pour soutenir pour
accompagner la réussite des communes
nouvelles existantes et l'émergence de
nouvelles communes nouvelles et
également avec grâce à la l'évolution
législative permise par Françoise Gatel
l'émergence de communes communautés
réponse originale pertinente pour
dépasser le clivage que l'on constate
parfois entre les grandes incarteurs
communalités et le fait communal pour
que cesse ce sentiment et plus que
sentiment cette réalité de dépossession
du pouvoir des maires de façon donc dans
une approche originale et volontaire qui
permet regroupement de communes au sein
d'une commune
communauté de fusionner les compétences
municipales et intercommunales et
d'avoir un établissement nouveau qui
respecte la réalité géographique
physique historique de chaque entité
sans la travestir la réussite d'une
commune nouvelle ne peut passer que sur
le volontariat la réussite d'une commune
nouvelle ne peut passer que par un
projet de territoire la résine d'une
commune nouvelle ne peut pas comme sur
une intercommunalité reposer simplement
sur des bonifications financières
initiales ceci étant les bonifications
financières et les intérêts financiers
doivent être garantis la commune
nouvelle ne saurait se traduire par une
perte de moyens financiers comme cela
peut être le cas par des absurdités
juridiques administratives qu'il nous
faut combattre et corriger
quel que soit les approches des uns ou
des autres et je terminerai l'assure
assurez-vous les témoignages des uns ou
des autres quel que soit les rapports y
compris de l'igéa nous devons absolument
nous opposer à une bureaucratisation de
la commune nouvelle le Léviathan de
l'état des inspections de ceux qui
croient savoir à la place de ceux qui
pratiquent ne doit pas se traduire par
une bureaucratisation une schématisation
la création de comité Adobe obligatoire
de machin de machins et de machins qui
nous consomment du temps de l'énergie
qui nous éloigne des résultats concrets
donc nous lirons avec attention tous les
rapports qui nous seront fournis mais
nous garderons notre souveraineté notre
indépendance et notre liberté d'action
pour les communes nouvelles ne
deviennent pas un bidule de plus
inutile dans le fonctionnement juridico
administratif français alors oui des
avancées sont encore nécessaires pour
accompagner les élus et je vois que
Agnès Canadair est le suit avec
attention et je la remercie de son
action il faut accorder plus de
souplesse aux communes nouvelles pour
leur permettre une organisation et une
gestion adaptée à la réalité à la
dimension géographique du territoire
concerné mieux prendre en compte la
superficie le nombre de communes
regroupées notamment en ce qui concerne
les effets de seuil et avec les
problématiques sur la DSR sur les gens
du voyage etc mais cela va être abordé
je ne vais pas d'effleurer l'intégralité
de ce qui va être présenté y compris ce
panorama que nous allons révéler en
exclusivité mondiale ici monsieur le
Président il faut sortir des
atermoiements des atermoiements
financiers qui ralentissent très
sérieusement depuis 2020 avec la crise
covid l'émergence de communes nouvelles
les projets de communes nouvelles ne
doivent pas être perdantes en termes de
dotation avec des principes très simples
qu'on doit rappeler
il faut renforcer les mesures
financières incitatives sur les trois
premières années pour susciter les
vocation comme je disais tout l'amour et
l'intérêt peuvent se rejoindre
et puis deuxièmement il faut protéger
durablement les communes nouvelles des
pertes de dotation un principe très
simple inscrivons le fait qu'une commune
nouvelle ne peut jamais percevoir moins
de DGF que la somme de ce qui était
perçu au préalable par les communes
fondatrices avant leur regroupement
c'est cela que nous devons inscrire et
c'est cela là-dessus que l'on doit être
très vigilant sur l'avenir de relation
avec l'État et puis enfin catalyser
stimuler ces communes communautés ont
montré l'intérêt à nos adhérents je
crois que tout passe et je regarde nos
mères et président la DD tout passe par
l'explication la commune nouvelle est
mal connue et peu connue et il y a un
travail véritablement pédagogique
doit s'emparer l'Association des maires
de France est-ce que nous allons faire à
l'avenir évidemment alors pour toutes
ces raisons bien merci monsieur le
Président merci à vous tous de votre
mobilisation
urbide et Orbit c'est-à-dire également
en visioconférence et oui les communes
nouvelles
préfigurent l'avenir d'une performance
publique qui permettra de concilier le
respect des contribuables le service aux
usagers et le sentiment d'appartenance à
la même communauté nationale et locale
par la décentralisation par la
subsidiarité c'est-à-dire par la
proximité par la responsabilité et donc
par la liberté merci
merci monsieur le Président de la MF
avant de passer à la première séquence
je passe la parole à Françoise Gatel
pour un dernier mot d'introduction à ces
travaux
monsieur le Président du Sénat monsieur
président de la MF chergérard chère
David cher Jacques pélissan Monsieur le
Directeur Général de l'mf qui nous avons
beaucoup travaillé cher Philippe
Chalopin qui
à l'AMF portait avec conviction et
ardeur le sujet de la commune nouvelle
je voudrais salué tout particulièrement
mes collègues de la délégation
collectivités ils sont nombreux et je
les en remercie je vous salue tous et je
vous salue aussi ceux qui sont connectés
avec nous sur le sujet alors en
introduction pour présenter les débats
que nous aurons je suis heureuse que
nous affirmions vous monsieur président
du Sénat et monsieur le président de
l'AMF l'enjeu qui est le nôtre
aujourd'hui de savoir inventer des
possibles pour réconcilier nos
concitoyens avec l'action publique et
surtout garantir l'E de l'action
publique jusqu'au dernier kilomètre mais
jusqu'au dernier habitant et je pense
que cette invention de possible qu'il
est la commune nouvelle est une réponse
elle n'est pas la réponse qui impose
partout mais elle est une réponse dont
les élus et les territoires peuvent
se dire et nous savons au Sénat combien
nous sommes les défenseurs du sens de la
responsabilité des élus locaux et de la
confiance qu'il doit exister entre
l'État le législateur naturellement et
ses élus locaux qui sont comptables de
tout parce que apporter d'engueulades et
non seulement pour gérer le présent mais
aussi pour construire l'avenir car je
crois que les élus territoriaux sont
aussi des entrepreneurs de territoire et
on l'oublie parfois un peu trop souvent
donc aujourd'hui c'est l'occasion de
pratiquer un exercice qui n'est pas
commun dans notre pays c'est celui de
l'évaluation puisque nous allons
ensemble faire le bilan de cette de ce
dispositif de commune nouvelle et je
sais que le président du Sénat et tout
le Sénat est très attaché à l'évaluation
des lois de l'expérimentation parce que
ça nous permettrait peut-être d'avancer
de manière plus sereine plus sage et
plus pertinente c'est un avis personnel
que j'ai tendance à beaucoup partager la
question que nous nous posons
aujourd'hui c'est est-ce que la commune
nouvelle a renforcé la capacité des
territoires tout en conjuguant la
proximité dont nous avons tant besoin
mais en ceintant ou en se musclant en
efficacité est-ce qu'elle parvient
inscrire son projet
où son action dans un véritable projet
de territoire partagé partagé entre les
communistes mais aussi partager avec les
habitants et partager avec les ensembles
des acteurs sans gommer ce qui est
l'histoire de de chacun et de
ces communes avons décidé d'emprunter à
nouveau chemin et puis nous sommes ici
au Parlement on peut s'empêcher
d'évaluer nous-mêmes notre action et de
nous demander si le cadre législatif
permet aujourd'hui de faire face à des
situations très différentes
d'un département à l'autre il y a des
départements il y a peu de communes et
des communes importantes en taille
d'autres où il y a beaucoup de communes
et des communes faibles en taille et on
voit bien qu'ici le président du Sénat
le dit et le port de la différenciation
et la clé de la réussite de l'action
publique alors
nous
constatons aujourd'hui que le vent de la
commune nouvelle moi qui suis bretonne
je parle souvent devant et de météo il
s'est un peu calmé et un peu assagi on
est dans une période un peu de stabilité
alors que doit-on tirer comme
enseignement tout ça moi j'apprécie
beaucoup ce que dit David Lina nous
sommes passés de 36 000 à moins de 35000
ça n'est pas rien quand on sait Jacques
Pélissard l'attachement au fait communal
qui en quelque sorte le cœur du réacteur
de de l'action publique et l'objectif de
Jacques Pélissard de la MFD n'a jamais
été de diminuer le nombre de communes en
disant la France sera performante il
sera extrêmement démocratique quand nous
serons descendus à 10000 communes ça n'a
aucun sens et la volonté de Jacques
Pélissard de la MF et du Sénat c'était
de permettre que la commune qui est
vraiment le cœur de l'ancrage
territorial elle puisse se muscler en
capacité et s'engager dans une pérennité
parce qu'elle sera plus forte c'était
l'esprit donc si des esprits chagrins
trouvent que tout ça ces mots si timide
bon je pense qu'ils sont plus des
théoriciens des pratiquants puisqu'il
faut reconnaître que la commune Noël
c'est quand même une aventure et c'est
une aventure humaine partagée qui est
parfois compliqué en tout cas si
certains disent que la baisse du nombre
de communes est faible ça doit pas
justifier l'inaction et la race sur
image et je pense que cela a été dit par
le président du Sénat et par le
président l'islam aujourd'hui
nos élus sont préoccupés ils l'ont été
par la covid qui ralentit le process de
mise en place des communes aujourd'hui
nous avons des obsessions de hausse de
coût d'énergie assez justifiée que les
élus sont vraiment ancrées dans des
réalités des urgences c'est qu'il est
difficile quand on est en situation de
crise de se projeter sur l'avenir il
convient que nous permettions aux élus
d'avoir ce temps de penser à
l'avenir et je crois que
les préfets devraient je le dis
accompagner ou s'assurer de la diffusion
des lois nos collègues qui sont là
aujourd'hui Agnès canaillé
rouge qui demain nous présenterons un
rapport extrêmement intéressant et qui
vous passionnera sur les services des
concentrés de l'État nous explique qu'il
y a plus de 3 cas des élus qui ne
connaissent pas les nouveaux dispositifs
législatives
et que la boulimie parfois normative et
la boulimie législatif et que tout ça
s'emballe et que les aiguilles n'ont pas
le temps de travailler d'être informé et
je pense qu'il est important que ce
travail soit fait et aujourd'hui cela
cela y participe et cela a été dit aussi
au-delà des raisons conjoncturelles on a
des effets
qui sont dus à des conséquences
négatives que ici nous avons souligné
mais nous ne sommes pas entendus quand
vous créez une commune nouvelle et que
vous avez un impact négatif par des
effets de seuil que vous atteignez alors
même que vous continuez à être un
territoire rural vous avez une
obligation en pour les gens du voyage
j'avais une obligation en logements
sociaux etc alors que la réalité
les attentes et les besoins ne
correspondent pas à ça moi je pense
qu'il faut qu'on ait le à force hybride
dans cette maison de dire que la commune
nouvelle ne doit pas générer des effets
induits catastrophiques et qui n'ont qui
n'ont pas de sens c'est très c'est très
très important enfin la commune nouvelle
moi je le redis j'ai lu un rapport de
gens extrêmement brillants récemment je
le dis et je l'affirme et nous l'avons
dit ici la commune nouvelle ne peut être
imposée à quiconque ni par la loi ni par
une sorte de commission départementale
qui dessinerait une carte territoriale
c'est le contraire de ce que c'est la
commune nouvelle c'est un chemin que des
élus décide d'emprunter pour
l'efficacité et
l'ancrage dans leur territoire d'un
avenir et que si une route difficile
compliquée courageuse il convient
d'aider les élus et de les accompagner
mais on a vu pardonnez-moi les effets de
la loi notre ou de brillants esprits
penser savoir que c'est à partir de
15000 habitants qu'une intercommunalité
serait performante conséquent avant nous
avait dit que c'était à hauteur de 5000
un seuil n'a jamais fait la réussite de
l'action publique et n'a jamais fait
l'affection sociétalecte affirmons le
ici permettons aux élus de se saisir de
tout ça et de comprendre que la commune
nouvelle c'est à la fois un mariage de
raison on le fait pour avoir un avenir
mais ceci un mariage d'affection je peux
pas dire mariage d'amour un mariage
d'affection parce qu'il y a
effectivement cette affection
sociétative qui fait qu'on partage
ensemble un certain nombre un certain
nombre de choses donc gardons cette
pépite de liberté qui l'examen de la
responsabilité dans les élus locaux sont
les premiers je veux dire les premiers
les premiers apôtres c'est l'agilité
l'intelligence territoriale qui se
concrétise dans la commune nouvelle et
sincèrement les bien réveillé dans ce
pays ont vu pendant la crise sanitaire
combien l'intelligence territoriale et
l'agilité était les clés de la survie et
de et de la réussite et donc cette
commune nouvelle elle est faite par des
hommes et des femmes c'est un chemin
compliqué pour l'avoir fait je mesure la
difficulté mais en tout cas je pense que
dans une société qui dispersait un peu
perdue nous avons besoin d'un ancrage et
que la commune reste l'ancrage les gens
disent toujours je suis de tel endroit
il nous avons besoin même si nous nous
faisons que passer dans certaines
communes c'est un repère c'est un
élément d'identité un élément
d'existence c'est qu'il faut savoir
consolider pour être audacieux alors
nous allons avoir deux séquences animées
par Monsieur Franck le marc demain info
il savait être intéressant la première
c'est la démocratie faire vivre la comme
nouvel an on nous Inter souvent sur ce
qui serait un truc d'élus qui décidera
entre eux sincèrement
je sais le président l'a rappelé que là
la commune nouvelle se fait sans engager
sans participer d'une manière adaptée
les habitants ça marche pas et que ça
n'est pas pour moi un référendum ou une
consultation en fin de process qui va
assurer la garantie de la concertation
et puis deuxième point c'est quelle
nouvelle élan pour les communes
nouvelles parce que
l'avenir nous intéresse beaucoup alors
avant de de conclure cette introduction
si je puis dire je voudrais partager
avec vous quelques mots du poète
Lamartine que j'avais emprunté comme
dans ma ville de Châteaugiron où j'étais
mère nous avons lancé la création d'une
commune nouvelle à trois
je me suis dit mais les gens ils vont se
demander pourquoi on fait ça et donc
Lamartine m'avait beaucoup inspiré parce
que cette phrase était celle-ci je lis
dans l'avenir la raison du présent et
c'est bien parce que nous choisissons un
avenir pour nos communes que nous
bouleversons un peu notre présence et
d'autres le disent autrement et c'est
rappelez-vous le film du guépard où l'on
dit il faut que tout bouge pour que rien
ne bouge et en tout cas chers Jacques
pélissa il faut que tu bouges pour que
le cœur de la commune continue à battre
avec force avec générosité pour le
meilleur de nos territoires et le
meilleur de notre pays merci à tous
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la sénatrice bonjour à tous
je suis ça a été dit Françoise Gatel
Franck Lemarque rédacteur en chef de
mère info et donc nous nous retrouvons
pour cette septième rencontre nationale
des communes nouvelles donc ça fait
maintenant 7 ans que chaque année l'AMF
organise s'est rencontré pour dresser le
bilan comme ça a été dit faire une
évaluation de ce qui s'est passé et puis
débattre et évoquer les pistes pour
l'avenir à un moment où on l'a dit le
mouvement des communes nouvelles à cause
des élections municipales et du
renouvellement des conseils municipaux
et à cause du covid a connu un être
ralentissement on va discuter des pistes
qui permettraient de peut-être le
relancer et leur donner un nouveau
souffle je vais simplement vous donner
quelques informations très pratiques
avant qu'on commence les débats
eux-mêmes donc je salue également les
gens qui nous qui sont connectés avec
nous il y a à peu près 80 personnes en
visioconférence
j'indique à chacun que après chaque
séquence on fera une séance de
questions-réponses avec le public le
public qui est là présentiel comme on
dit et le public qui est en visio
simplement le public en visio nous
posera ces questions par écrit il y a un
chat qui permet de poser des questions
par écrit et il n'y a pas de
possibilités techniques de les poser
directement en vidéo n'essayez pas de
changer les paramètres de votre webcam
ça ne marchera pas je demanderai à
chaque personne à chaque intervenant de
bien vouloir se présenter y compris les
personnes qui posent des questions par
écrit un présentez-vous et dites-nous de
quelle commune vous venez
je signale également que ces débats sont
enregistrés sont filmés sont
enregistrées et sont diffusés en direct
en ce moment sur le site du Sénat et sur
le site de l'AMF voilà je crois que j'ai
à peu près fait le tour nous avons la
salle jusqu'à 13h on doit pas dépasser
cette torreur là donc je demanderai
aussi à chacun d'être relativement
concis et d'aller à l'essentiel dans nos
échanges voilà alors on va passer tout
de suite à la première séquence je
signale que c'est nos travaux seront
présidés qu'aux présidé par Françoise
Gatel David lister mais aussi à côté de
par Philippe Chalopin donc maire de
Baugé en Anjou qui nous dira quelques
mots dans quelques minutes et Paul
Carrera mère de Morcenx la nouvelle donc
ils sont les deux co-présidents du
groupe de travail sur les communes
nouvelles à l'Association des maires de
France et puis également Jean-Marc Vasse
va nous rejoindre vers 11h
je signale je n'ai pas dit tout à
l'heure que Monsieur Carrère est n'est
pas parmi en présentiel mais qu'il est
en visioconférence je le salue
voilà écoutez je vais demander aux
intervenants de la première séquence de
nous rejoindre peut-être et puis donc
cette première séquence démocratie faire
vivre la commune nouvelle va nous
permettre de parler de questions aussi
diverses que les maires délégués leur
rôle le rôle de la population
dans avant et après le démarrage du
projet donc nous aurons Christine
Blanchet Cédric axerre et Éric Moisan et
Thomas janvier qui vont nous rejoindre
non je vous dis une bêtise excusez-moi
il y a pas assez de place donc on va ils
vont intervenir de leur place
excusez-moi je n'avais pas compris ce
détail là Philippe Chalopin pour
commencer vous voulez peut-être nous
dire quelques mots sur sur cette
première séquence donc on m'a dit on va
parler un peu évaluation dans la
première séquence et puis on parlera à
venir dans la seconde
la démocratie quel rôle la démocratie et
quel rôle la population elle-même
peuvent et doivent jouer dans un projet
de commune nouvelle on va vous écouter
et puis après on aura l'occasion de
faire parler des élus qui nous
raconteront leur témoignage merci
bonjour à tous monsieur le Président et
Sénat monsieur le Président de
l'Association des maires de France
madame sénateur Mesdames et Messieurs
les parlementaires monsieur le Président
d'honneur de l'AMF mais chers collègues
démocratie on pourrait penser que ça ne
rime pas tout à fait avec comme une
nouvelle quand parce qu'il y a certaines
personnes qui pensent qu'on fait une
commune nouvelle contre quelque chose on
fait pas une commune nouvelle contre on
fait une commune nouvelle pour et donc
effectivement
on consulte la population en amont on
travaille avec la population et
l'objectif de tumeur d'une commune
nouvelle c'est effectivement de faire
participer parce qu'on a d'autres
problématiques peut-être plus plus plus
difficile à régler en termes de densité
vous l'avez évoqué on va vers la
population parce que on se doit
d'embarquer tout le monde et c'est là
parfois qu'il peut y avoir des échecs
c'est lorsqu'on ne réussit pas embarquer
tout le monde la commune nouvelle de
Beaujoire d'Anjou a été créée en mars
enfin on l'a voté en mars 2012 donc on a
pratiquement 10 ans d'expérience de
retour les chemins sont pas toujours
simple ils sont parfois semés d'embûches
le fait de d'expliquer aux habitants ce
qu'est la commune nouvelle et est un
challenge le plus souvent mais je peux
vous dire qu'à travers deux expériences
fortes comme le covid et les incendies
de cet été la ville de beaujolins
d'Anjou a été ravagée par un incendie
qui a détruit plus de 1600 hectares je
peux vous dire que vous pouvez aller
interroger
les habitants du territoire ils vont
vous expliquer ce qu'est une commune
nouvelle c'est un moyen de mutualiser
les moyens à 100% c'est un moyen aussi
d'aider le la petite commune la plus
faible parce que les incendies sont
produits sur une commune déléguée qui
comptait que 250 habitants donc tout le
monde s'est mobilisé autour de cette
commune et je pense que la commune
nouvelle dans ces moments difficiles là
prend tout son sens parce que et on me
l'a dit
sans la commune nouvelle on n'aurait pas
pu régler ce genre de difficulté faire
face à un incendie de cette importance
donc c'est vrai que j'ai lu avec
beaucoup de déceptions le rapport de
l'Inspection Générale administration sur
les communes nouvelles on nous dit bilan
décevant
je voulais simplement faire remarquer
que avant la loi sur les communes
nouvelles il y avait la loi Marcellin
lequel bilan
quel bilan
la loi sur les communes nouvelles les
lois répétitives c'est la commune
nouvelle on dépassé le stade des fusions
et des roues points de la loi Marcellin
et on voit que il y a aujourd'hui des
idées qui gèrent encore alors c'est vrai
que nous avons besoin d'un deuxième
souffle c'est clair on en est tous
conscients parce que notre commune
nouvelle elle a besoin de vivre mais à
un moment où on commence à affronter des
crises à nouveau financière
énergétique transition écologique il
faudra qu'on m'explique comment petite
commune ou plusieurs petites communes ou
des communes moyennes peuvent relever
ces défis seuls donc plus que jamais il
va être nécessaire effectivement de se
regrouper alors ça peut pas se faire
effectivement au détriment des habitants
bien évidemment mais nous nous j'avais
réagi de manière assez vive lorsqu'on
avait tenté de d'intégrer l'obligation
de recourir au référendum
mais on interroge on consulte notre
population en amont avant de se lancer
dans une dans une la création d'une
commune nouvelle donc c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui faire vivre la commune
nouvelle c'est peut-être notre
difficulté tous les jours peut-être plus
qu'ailleurs peut-être plus qu'ailleurs
parce que peut-être plus qu'ailleurs il
faut fédérer davantage les habitants
faut gommer les différences faut
expliquer que ceux qui avaient des
situations un peu plus privilégiées
doivent faire des concessions pour ceux
qui sont peut-être dans des situations
un peu plus délicates puis cet embarquer
aussi dans le train c'est ça aussi la
commune nouvelle c'est une une grande
solidarité et c'est de cela des réalités
on la voit effectivement tester à
l'épreuve des des grands défis que j'ai
évoqués tout à l'heure donc c'est vrai
que la démocratie la façon de faire
vivre notre commune nouvelle est
importante
alors merci Monsieur chalpin pour en
parler justement j'ai commencé par me
tourner vers Christine Blanchet donc
vous êtes maire de loire-auxances en
Loire-Atlantique d'une commune nouvelle
de qui a fusionné quatre communes et qui
a été créé le 1er janvier 2016 donc
si je comprends bien la commune nouvelle
n'a pas été créée en associant
directement la population mais la
nouvelle équipe municipale qui est
arrivée en 2020 a fait le choix
justement d'associer plus plus
étroitement la population est-ce que
vous pouvez nous raconter un petit peu
ce qui s'est passé
déjà je voudrais remercier l'AMF et puis
le le Sénat de pouvoir nous permettre de
témoigner localement de ce qu'on de ce
qu'on mène je pense que le bottomov dont
Monsieur Lisnard a passé à parler tout à
l'heure ce prouve ce matin donc en fait
moi j'ai la chance d'être mère de la
plus belle des communes de France je
vois mon collègue à côté de moi qui va
me contrarier probablement là dessus
donc
de
l'Est du de Loire-Atlantique en effet
bordé au sud par la Loire et au nord par
l'auxence et moi j'étais maire de la
plus petite des communes en 2014 avant
qu'on crée la commune nouvelle en 2016
et en effet nous on l'a créé très
rapidement sans concerter les habitants
et sans projet territoire ce que moi à
l'époque j'avais dénoncé mais bon voilà
ça correspond à un bassin de vie on
avait des attaches entre nous et c'est
probablement un des critères de contexte
qui nous a fait conduire cette démarche
participative que l'on a conduite en
2022 parce que justement les habitants
n'avaient pas été concertés le deuxième
élément de contexte c'est que
on avait quand on a fait notre programme
électoral pendant la campagne un
attachement particulier et on l'a
toujours à la démocratie participative
qu'on estime complémentaire à la
démocratie représentative et pendant le
la campagne on a fait des ateliers avec
les habitants qui ont soulevé ce gros
enjeu l'identité de la commune nouvelle
qu'elle n'avait qui n'avait pas été
traitée en effet et puis quand on a été
élu et ben on a mis en place des
instances participatives le Conseil de
Participation citoyens et des instances
élargi et puis le troisième élément de
contexte c'est qu'en effet quand dès
qu'on a été élu on s'est dit bah il faut
qu'on fasse ce projet de territoire donc
qui est la traduction en action concrète
de notre projet politique et qui nous
permet d'avoir une vision à long terme
au-delà de la simple addition de quatre
projets communaux
et entre temps on a été retenu au
programme petite ville de demain de et
de la mi centre bourg du conseil
départemental ce qui nous a permis de
recruter un chef de projet qui nous
accompagne sur la construction de ce
projet de territoire et Lise qui est
dans qui m'accompagne aujourd'hui
et donc on s'est dit bah c'est pas aux
outils de nous guider sur le projet
territoire c'est bien nous de créer le
projet de territoire et de solliciter
les outils qui vont bien et du coup cet
enjeu d'identité comme préalable à la
réflexion sur le projet territoire donc
début 2022 on s'est dit il faut se faire
accompagner il faut qu'on se fasse
accompagner sur cette réflexion sur
l'identité
la traduction dans le projet territoire
avec la participation des habitants donc
on s'est lancé dans l'aventure alors
déjà via Bruded les communes bretonnes
connaissent probablement c'est un donc
loi Atlantique est en Bretagne et on en
fait partie
on a c'est un réseau d'élus qui met
justement les élus en lien sur des
marges des projets et on a pu justement
être en lien avec trois communes de
Bretagne dont Jugon-les-Lacs
dont on s'est inspiré de leur cahier des
charges évidemment qui ont mené une
démarche similaire et puis dans ce
cahier des charges nous on souhaitait
trois choses fortes la première à la
représentativité entendre cette majorité
silencieuse qu'on entend pas puisqu'elle
est silencieuse mais aussi
les habitants et les acteurs extérieurs
de la commune comme on est perçu à
l'extérieur et aussi faire participer
les agents et les élus deuxième chose
dans ce cahier des charges questionner
sur qu'est-ce que la commune uvale
actuellement et qu'est-ce qu'on veut
qu'elle devienne donc avec des notions
d'appartenance de fierté un jeu de
projection sur qu'est-ce qu'on voudrait
sur la première page du bulletin
municipal de notre commune en 2050 et la
troisième chose c'est quelle est la
plus-value de la commune nouvelle pour
vous donc ces trois notions là et
ensuite on a donc voulu un comité de
pilotage d'agents et de lui mais aussi
demande du conseil de participation
citoyenne et une démarche très rapide on
la conduite de mars à de en juillet 2022
et donc plusieurs prestataires ont
répondu à ce qu'il y ait des charges
dont ceux qu'on a retenu évidemment donc
je les cite parce que on a vraiment très
bien travaillé donc c'est le facteur
urbain qui est des spécialistes de
l'aménagement et du et de la
transformation des territoires et de la
concertation et puis inkipit sur le
marketing territorial avec Alice qui
doit être dans la salle aussi qui
coordonnait cette équipe là et qui nous
a fait la proposition de noms de la
démarche foire au sens voilà donc avec
Alice Elise on était bien entouré donc
on a lancé des temps forts de rencontre
des habitants enfin c'est elle qui ont
fait tout ça
un questionnaire en ligne pour tous ceux
qu'on n'avait pas pu rencontrer et puis
un temps fort de restitution début
juillet alors les résultats ils sont
plusieurs niveaux et les suites qu'on
vend à y donner sont plusieurs niveaux
aussi alors déjà les premières remarques
des prestataires c'est de dire on a
atteint le seuil de
exploitable pour vraiment que le les
retours soient représentatif même si
pour nous c'était pas suffisant mais
c'était c'était déjà ça dans le timing
qui était le nôtre et surtout très
convergent et enfin une démarche qui
nous engage désormais puisque 160
habitants ont souhaité être informés
voire associé à la démarche et l'autre
chose c'est l'importance de nos
associations on est il y a à peu près
150 associations à au sens et le fait
que l'identité se créera probablement
par les projets à venir aussi alors sur
les livrables on a une première carte de
notre commune on en avait pas donc ça
c'était assez étonnant mais en effet
première chose deuxième chose c'est que
les habitants ont priorisé systématique
de politique publique que l'on va
intégrer évidemment dans notre projet de
territoire et c'est déjà le cas et qui
vont donner probablement lieu à des
instances participatives auxquelles les
160 habitants sont particulièrement
associés et la troisième chose on a
souhaité que s'abotisse aussi un fil
rouge sur l'identité comme un manifeste
une grille de lecture et ce qui est
ressorti chez nous c'est le lien le lien
qu'on pourra décliner dans pas mal de ce
projet et sur lequel on va déjà
travailler la semaine prochaine avec le
conseil de participation citoyenne s'il
y a eu des idées comme un slogan comme
un label comme un événement etc et là
l'enjeu c'est comment on associe les 160
habitants là dessus voilà donc en fait
on sait que l'identité se créera aussi
par rapport à tous ces projets et ce et
ces éléments
identitaires la quatrième chose et ça
fera lien avec l'importance des merdes
délégués comme une délégués c'est que
53% des habitants voient une plus-value
à la commune nouvelle quand 47 il voit
une faiblesse et surtout la peur de la
proximité de perdre la proximité et la
réactivité et nous on a souhaité pendant
la campagne électorale maintenir les
mers délégués et les communes déléguées
alors peut-être parce que moi je l'ai
été avant et que j'y ai vu un intérêt
parce qu'on est passé de 76 à 33 élus
donc la plus petite des communes n'a
plus que 5 élus par exemple
et puis parce qu'on a des bourdes
distants au maximum de 10 km donc
l'enjeu de la proximité se posait
vraiment et on la traduit par les rôles
de chacun donc les adjoints de pôle qui
sont bien connus mais les mers délégués
au-delà de leur rôle d'epj ou d'être
officiers d'état civil on les appelle
des adjoints territoire c'est-à-dire
qu'ils ont vraiment ce rôle de proximité
de lien avec les habitants les acteurs
et garant de la cohérence de la
politique publique des adjoints de pôles
sur leur sur leur commune déléguée et en
lien avec les autres mères délégués et
évidemment les élus de leur commune
déléguées donc voilà donc on traduit ça
c'est une gouvernance exigeante mais
pour lesquelles il faut mettre de
l'huile chaque jour dans la
communication de tout le monde mais
c'est complémentaire entre la proximité
la réactivité et l'équilibre des
politiques dans la commune nouvelle
et donc ça se traduit par le projet de
territoire parce que là on est en train
de d'acter les équipements que l'on
souhaite équipements et services dans
chaque commune délégué celles qu'on
n'aura pas dans chaque commune déléguée
mais en évitant que ce soit toujours sur
la grosse commune mais comment on fait
pour que chaque habitant y a accès on le
fait aussi dans la gouvernance puisque
les mers délégates joint territoire sont
associés aux commissions au bureau
municipal évidemment et puis au Conseil
communaux en fait ils animent une
réunion d'élus de leur commune déléguée
pour avoir ce lien de proximité et puis
moi évidemment j'essaye de mettre de
l'huile dans tout ça j'en suis garante
par des rencontres régulières avec les
adjointes pôles comme les adjoints
territoire et enfin via les services
pour que le maire délégué et un lien
particulier aussi avec les services
voilà donc juste je voudrais juste finir
moi qui suis aussi vice-présidente d'une
interco pour moi on parle souvent du
bloc communal au niveau d'une interco la
commune nouvelle c'est un bloc communal
aussi une interco très intégrée où il
faut de la subsidiarité en effet et
laisser la proximité aux communes
déléguées voilà
merci merci beaucoup de ce témoignage on
aura l'occasion de le commenter ou si
vous avez des questions n'hésitez pas à
les noter à les garder pour tout à
l'heure on va continuer les témoignages
avec Cédric axerre donc votre voisin
sinon géographique du moins dans cette
salle maire de Thaon-les-Vosges dans les
Vosges donc 9100 habitants trois
communes créer en janvier au 1er janvier
2016 alors voici je les informations
sont exactes vous avez organisées
consultation des habitants à propos du
changement de nom de la commune nouvelle
c'est assez original racontez-nous ça
merci pour reprendre bonjour à toutes et
tous merci pour cette invitation on va
prendre l'insolence de David Lisnard je
n'ai pas lu le rapport de l'igéa je ne
lirai pas visiblement je crois que c'est
pas la peine de le faire puisque les
synthèses ont été ont été données et je
viens d'un territoire où le phénomène de
la commune nouvelle est quand même pas
franchement vogue puisque dans les
Vosges on se méfie encore parfois des
Alsaciens donc on a évidemment et
Christian Poncelet et Christian Poncelet
qui a présidé cette vénérable assemblée
avait dit axaire un village une église
une église un village donc vous voyez
que il y a sur le plan culturel parfois
des réticences à avancer et puis il y a
un autre phénomène de contexte c'est que
moi j'ai battu le maire qui a mis en
place la commune la commune nouvelle
avec ses collègues des deux communes
délégués qui sont en cours et girement
pour une raison assez précise c'est que
là il y avait vraiment une absence
totale de consultation moi je pense pas
qu'il faille forcément faire un
référendum même si je l'ai fait donc
j'ai plus facile à dire que c'est bien
de le faire mais c'est pas obligatoire
je pense pas que ce soit obligatoire il
faut bien discuter avec ces gens et puis
sur le nom de la commune puisqu'il avait
eu la triste idée d'appeler sa capavenir
Vosges et donc vous imaginez quand vous
détériorialisez autant votre votre patte
là vous forcément générer une énorme
tension et je pense que c'est grâce à ça
que j'ai été Luère d'ailleurs en 2020
donc peut-être entre autres difficultés
que la ville avait sorti ce que je dois
dire
c'est également que à mon sens il y a
pas un seul format de commune nouvelle
qui soit valable pour tous puisque nous
on a la chance d'être en immédiat de
proximité c'est un petit territoire
c'est 25 km². donc moi je pense par
exemple que à mon échelle le rôle des
maires délégués peut se re questionner
au prochain monde par exemple je pense
qu'il serviront à rien à partir du
moment où quand on réfléchit à tous les
projets que ce soit l'entretien de la
route que ce soit le schéma des
mobilités que ça soit le PAF que ce soit
le déovh que ça soit aussi documents qui
sont vraiment essentiels et qui donnent
ensuite quelque chose d'hyper concret
aux gens sur le terrain si vous avez
toujours LA bonne réflexion sur le bon
périmètre en oubliant jamais les
communes déléguées ce qui peut arriver
encore parfois mécaniquement par le fait
de l'histoire si vous ne les oubliez pas
en général vous allez les inclure dans
une même logique et apporter beaucoup de
nouveaux services que les communes
n'avaient pas autrefois et le résultat
du référendum qu'on a fait lui novembre
2020 était intéressant et il a été
l'exact contraire de ce que j'imaginais
dans les réponses puisque on a fait des
bureaux de vote dans les petites
communes et plus la communauté petit
plus petite plus il était favorable
au regroupement de la commune à la
commune nouvelle le petit village de 180
habitants a voté pour à 95 % le village
de 1000 habitants à voter à 85 % elle
est à honnête ont voté pour à 75 % que
et moi je pensais que ça allait être
l'inverse plus on était petit plus on
avait sans doute un sentiment
d'appartenance géographique c'est pas
vrai parce que les gens ont vu le
résultat et ça c'est grâce à mon
prédécesseur c'est pas grâce à moi
puisque j'ai fait le référendum 6 mois
après les élections c'est que les gens
ont vu les bénéfices en termes de
fiscalité en termes d'équipement en
termes de politique d'assainissement et
d'eau potable etc etc je veux pas faire
la longue liste et donc faut pas avoir
peur des gens faut pas avoir peur de la
population pour mettre en place ce genre
de dispositif maintenant pour aller pour
aller plus loin parce que moi je me pose
la question nous elle a été faite
Est-Ouest alors que la logique
territoriale et géographique chez moi
elle est Nord-Sud et il serait très
pertinent que la commune du nord et la
commune du sud de chez moi nous
rejoignent sauf que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on nous est pas beaucoup
on a parlé des effets de seuil moi
aujourd'hui la DGF elle baisse
parce que si on se regroupe à mon avis
c'est parce qu'on est dans des
difficultés il faut pas se leurrer enfin
moi tous les cas dans les Vosges étaient
le cas baisse de tassion baisse de
population donc maintenant que la
population baisse la DGF elle baisse je
trouve ça assez sournois surtout qu'on a
fait des efforts assez colosseux et
qu'on a été très très aidé au départ
pour le faire et puis au sujet celui-là
aussi m'intéresse beaucoup ce que je
suis à 10 km d'Épinal en me dis que
c'est trop près pour être bourse pour
être cœur de ville peut-être ou petite
ville de demain et je pense que ça
serait bien de temps en temps qu'on
puisse nous mettre sur la table des
solutions un peu plus concrètes d'appui
quand on a des vrais logiques de bourses
puisque une commune nouvelle on le sait
elle est forcément équivalente à bassin
de vie donc il faudrait qu'on puisse
être appuyé de temps en temps sur un
certain nombre de projets pour lequel il
faudrait que la préfecture l'État et une
paire de lunettes qui puisse s'adapter
globalement au choix courageux qu'à
certains membres d'élus ont pu faire
puisque même si j'ai battu mon
prédécesseur je salue son initiative il
a il avait bien fait de le faire et on a
bien sûr généré un potentiel de
déploiement et d'activité sur la commune
qu'on aurait perdu sans cela donc
j'avais bien d'autres choses à dire mais
je crois que l'essentiel l'essentiel est
communiqué juste un petit mot sur les
comités de proximité qui ont été mis en
place dans les dans les quartiers de la
commune nouvelle quel est leur rôle oui
moi les conseils communaux moi aussi à
mon échelle ça servait à rien ça aurait
été j'aurais eu deux élus dans la
commune d'oncourt qui serait réunie donc
dans le blanc des yeux je suis pas sûr
qu'ils grand chose qui en serait sorti
donc on a mis en place des comités de
proximité c'est à dire que là on a vite
toute la population à venir 4 fois par
an à une réunion qui animait par le
maire délégué en présence du maire du
maire de la commune bien sûr où on va
les chats écrasés les panneaux qui
manquent etc et c'est ça aussi
globalement les réponses qui sont
attendues par les habitants même si
c'est pas toujours facile
merci on va continuer sur les
témoignages là encore vous pourrez tous
réagir après sur ces différents
témoignages en visioconférence Eric
Moisan donc mère on en parlait tout à
l'heure de de Madame Blanchet en parler
de Jugon-les-Lacs commune nouvelle dans
les Côtes-d'Armor 2500 habitants de
communes créés le premier janvier 2016
bonjour monsieur Moisan je ne sais pas
si on le voit et si on l'entend
on vous entend tout à fait bonjour là
aussi si vous pouviez nous parler un
petit peu des concertations qui sont
menées sur le territoire de votre
commune donc vous avez la particularité
d'être une commune nouvelle dans le
terme même de commune nouvelle et dans
le nom de la commune un Jugon-les-Lacs
commune nouvelle ça a été d'ailleurs une
un sujet de discussion avec les
habitants
complètement donc si je si je dois
rappeler un petit peu l'histoire d'un
autre comme une nouvelle donc on l'a
créé en 1er janvier 2016 moi j'étais
maire de la petite commune la réflexion
l'avait initié à l'échelle à l'échelle
de la communauté de communes où il y
avait si commune
très rapidement aussi trouvé à 4 dans la
discussion 3 après et au final on a fait
la commune qu'à deux communes moi qui
était plutôt enfin jeune mère je
considérais que
réfléchir aux communes nouvelles on
avait tout intérêt à le faire et être
maire c'est pas edmer pour sa place mais
pour réfléchir à l'avenir du territoire
et pourquoi je dis ça parce que quand je
suis amené à témoigner sur les communes
nouvelles alors beaucoup moins
maintenant mais dans l'ancien mandat je
disais les deux points à trancher dès le
départ c'est qui sera le maire et quel
sera le nom de la commune
nous les discussions se sont toujours
bien passées entre les deux communes la
population
a été associée uniquement
à travers deux réunions de réunions
publiques et des communications dans le
bulletin municipal mais on n'était pas
allés plus loin à l'époque et
la commune nouvelle failli ne pas se
faire uniquement par rapport au nom de
la commune et entre les collègues élus
de jumeaux qui souhaitaient jumeler que
ça reste Jugon-les-Lacs et et nous élu
de la petite commune d'olo ou pour aussi
que les gens se sentent concernés on
voulait modifier un petit peu le nom
sachant bien que Jugon-les-Lacs c'était
aussi une notoriété touristique qu'on ne
pouvait pas non plus totalement
l'effacer donc il en est ressorti Jugon
est là comme une nouvelle
depuis en effet dans ce nouveau mandat
alors j'ai été réélu quand j'étais réélu
il y avait deux listes si l'autisme ne
remettait pas en cause la commune parce
que c'est ça passe plutôt bien auprès de
son autre territoire l'état d'esprit
n'était pas tout à fait le même mais et
les électeurs avaient moi qui avait
porté haut et fort cette commune
nouvelle avec toute la latitude s'il le
souhaitait de ne pas me réunir donc
mon premier message quand j'ai été élu
c'était dire c'est la victoire de la
commune nouvelle mais pour autant comme
une nouvelle nous le nom commun nouvelle
c'est pas joli c'est long c'est
problématique on a eu souvent des
retours par rapport à ça et on a décidé
de lancer une consultation
dans à travers le bulletin municipal
pour
retirer ce mot commun une nouvelle
et sur sur 1200 1200 foyers donc la
commune nouvelle aujourd'hui c'est 2500
habitants donc à peu près 1200 foyers on
a eu un peu plus de 200 retours et à
99%, c'est de retour de retirer cette
particules comme une nouvelle et des
retours à la fois enfin un peu partout
sur sur la commune donc aujourd'hui
c'est ce qui on a pris la délibération
dans ce sens là c'est au ministère de
l'Intérieur maintenant de tranchées
si je dois en revenir sur les
consultations
sur la consultation de la population en
effet je le disais le choix de faire la
commune nouvelle
a été discuté dans les deux conseils
municipaux à l'époque mais pour autant
on a en effet pas fait de référendum
parce que alors avec sûrement une petite
appréhension du résultat c'était la
petite commune de 600 habitants qui se
regroupait avec la commune de 1800
habitants qui étaient à l'époque enfin à
l'époque on parle plus comme ça mais le
chef-lieu de canton donc on connaissait
un petit peu les rivalités entre le la
plus grande commune et la plus petite
commune mais pour autant il y avait des
habitudes de travail les associations
notamment le club de foot était déjà
regroupé on était en RPI il y avait les
services techniques travailler déjà un
petit peu ensemble bon voilà on a pris
la décision de de faire la commune
nouvelle et et ça s'est bien passé mais
dans ce nouveau mandat là on a considéré
que
faire territoire ensemble ça ne se
décrète pas ça se construit et et on
partait notamment de l'expérience aussi
que Jugon Les Lacs initialement c'était
déjà le regroupement de trois communes
entre trois petites commun qui s'était
regroupés en 1973 et puis ce qui existe
toujours d'ailleurs c'est que on a
différents comités des fêtes les gens
continuent à dire j'habite satignac pour
le coup c'était ça ignote les couilles
et bon donc du coup ce qui n'est pas ce
qui n'est pas un problème en soi mais on
voulait éviter de garder toujours ces
petites différences là et c'est de là
qu'on a décidé de faire un travail sur
l'identité de de la commune
en recrutant d'un cabinet et essayer de
mettre
enfin de mettre en avant ce qu'on
voulait faire ensemble ce qui nous unit
les uns et les autres et qu'est-ce qui
nous voulons faire de savoir de nous et
donc il y a eu tout un travail
intéressant de fait auprès de la
population à la fois des enquêtes en
ligne quel papier des rencontres sur sur
le marché marché hebdomadaire
et puis il en est ressorti un certain
nombre d'actions à mettre en place à la
fois sur les services sur le sur le
commerce sur le tourisme sur le sur la
vie associative culturel et l'identité
en tant que tel en tant que tel de la
commune alors des actions sur l'identité
par exemple
s'ensuit le recrutement de la cabinet
pour définir un logo commun qui ce qui
nous fait sens dans ce logo là c'est
aussi la refonte au total de la
signalétique sur la commune mais ce qui
en ressort surtout c'est
une grille de lecture de
de nos actions une grille des lectures
de nos actions publiques une grille de
lecture qu'on veut transmettre aussi aux
associations mais aussi aux entreprises
de la commune c'est à dire que dès lors
qu'il y a un projet est en cours ou le
choix est de mener
politique est-ce que
est-ce que toutes les décisions ou que
nous souhaitons prendre correspondre
tout au parti à cette grille de lecture
qui met en avant l'identité de la
commune donc que l'on souhaite porter
donc ça c'est vraiment
une des actions concrètes de qu'est-ce
qu'on veut faire ensemble
j'ai presque envie de dire que pour le
coup la commune après avoir pris la
décision de la commune nouvelle nous
avons décidé de d'associer beaucoup plus
la les concitoyens à la construction de
cette de cette commune nouvelle nous
avons eu aussi la chance d'être retenu
dans le programme petite ville de demain
où là
faisons un travail sur les commerces et
les services de proximité là aussi ce
sont des enquêtes qui sont menées auprès
des professionnels mais aussi des
concitoyens qu'est-ce qu'ils souhaitent
avoir sur le sur le sur la commune
et puis le
quand nous faisons le choix de faire une
commune nouvelle alors moi je dis
souvent
c'est quatre ces quatre bourgs
de foot tout ça dans des endroits
différents se pose clairement la
question de l'aménagement du territoire
de manque demain avec une notion
importante malgré tout la proximité la
centralité
mais à travers cet aménagement de la
commune il y a aussi quel lien en fait
entre les bourses et donc du coup nous
avons entamé toute une réflexion aussi
sur sur des
mobilité douce à travers à travers pour
essayer de réunir les quatre bourses les
quatre bourgs historiques
donc voilà j'ai à peu près fait le tour
sur tout ce que nous avons mis en place
sur la concertation
enfin comment associer la population ou
à la construction sur le coup de la
commune nouvelle une fois que le choix
était fait de créer cette communauté
merci donc la différence justement entre
un choix qui est fait avant le début du
processus après la fin du processus on
aura l'occasion d'en parler un dernier
témoignage celui de Thomas janvier donc
vous êtes dans la salle en face de moi
mère de
men rock on dit je me trompe pas dans en
Ille-et-Vilaine donc deux communes 5000
habitants créés au 1er janvier 2017
alors vous aussi un peu même question et
même témoignage ou autre témoignages sur
l'association de la population au projet
de commune nouvelle alors avant ou après
chez vous
merci alors tout d'abord bonjour à tout
le monde moi je tiens à remercier
d'avoir Françoise Gatel cher Françoise
pour son invitation et puis son
accompagnement puisqu'elle a accompagné
tout le processus notamment de cette de
cette de ce regroupement alors moi j'ai
la chance d'avoir accompagné le
processus en tant qu'élu et d'avoir été
le premier maire de la commune nouvelle
donc j'ai fait les plâtres on va dire de
cette commune nouvelle et je suis
également heureux d'être sur un
territoire on est dans le pays de
Fougères on est au nord de Rennes et
Françoise de sait très bien on est un
territoire qui aime la commune nouvelle
on l'expérimente assez aisément et
d'ailleurs je salue mon collègue et Marc
de Gouvion saphir qui est dans la salle
qui est le maire des portes du coblé
puisque sur 15 communes de Le Plessis
nous avons quatre communes nouvelles
donc c'est une expérience intéressante
que l'on a sur notre territoire alors
pour répondre à votre question
j'aimerais donner quelques alimenter un
peu le débat et donner quelques
principes que nous on a retiré de cette
fusion tout d'abord donc men rock vous
l'avez très bien prononcé
sur une fusion de deux communistes qui
arrivent à 5100 habitants aujourd'hui et
peut-être contrairement à certaines
exemples ou certaines expérimentations
nous ça a été une déclinaison naturelle
de notre base de vie d'emploi et je
pense que et on a l'expérience d'autres
communes nouvelles de notre territoire
avant de se lancer dans une aventure qui
est quand même considérable il faut se
poser la question de la cohérence de
l'enveloppe et parfois on voit des
coïnes nouvelles à trois quatre qui
posent problème parce que il y a cette
cohérence de bassin de vie nous on est
sur une histoire commune on a un bassin
qui est commun patrimoine architectural
cohérent et donc lorsque la loi de
monsieur pélissa est passée en 2015 des
si je me souviens c'était le 16 mars
2015 il y a dès le mois d'avril la
discussion a été engagée le Conseil les
deux conseils municipaux sont emparés de
cette réflexion là et on a été quasiment
quelques mois plus tard dans dans la
concrétisation
et peut-être avoir une indication pour
certains certaines communes qui
aimeraient tenter l'aventure nous avons
tenté par l'action commencer par une
fusion par l'action c'est à dire on a en
faisant l'acquisition d'équipements
communs pour nos services techniques et
en engageant dès le mois d'avril 2015
des recrutements conjoints pour les deux
communes mais ensemble et cette première
expérience a permis déjà de mettre les
agents au travail ensemble voilà ensuite
les élus si on part sur le processus
politique les élus sont pareils la
question et on a on a mis en place un
processus organisationnel qui a été très
clair dès le départ et très participatif
l'objectif c'était que l'ensemble des
élus puisse donner leur avis commencer à
travailler ensemble on a eu des comités
de pilotage un comité restreint et on a
constitué 7 groupes de travail d'élus
sur des thématiques très précises ce qui
a permis déjà de s'apprécier parce qu'on
peut vivre ensemble on peut avoir des
familles dans les deux communes si on ne
s'apprécie pas en tant que élus ça pose
quelques questions et donc ce travail
pendant plus de six mois a permis
d'aboutir le 20 juin 2016 à une
délibération conjointe à l'unanimité des
deux Conseils Municipaux sous forme une
charte de gouvernance qui avait été
demandé par le préfecture à l'époque et
qui comprenait un règlement intérieur et
qui bordait déjà en fait la commune
nouvelle qui allait arriver et puis on a
eu en le 29 août 2016
l'arrêté préfectoral qui a validé cette
commune nouvelle de domaine rock et qui
est devenu à côté du premier janvier
2017 donc une commune nouvelle pleine et
entière et donc cette année de travail
intense il a surtout été collaboratif et
avant de je dirais de de concrétiser le
regroupement ou la fusion et d'abord eu
ce travail de maturation politique des
deux Conseils Municipaux donc voilà ça
c'était le premier élément que je
voulais apporter comme témoignage mais
qui a permis de lever aussi un certain
nombre de doutes de la part des élus
vous parliez de la population de
l'application de la population
clairement
de mon point de vue il est très
compliqué de ne pas impliquer la
population parce que c'est un changement
non seulement de nom il disait tout à
l'heure un changement de périmètre mais
aussi un changement de pratique et donc
il est essentiel que la population soit
présente dès le départ et un peu comme
je crois que c'était le collègue tout à
l'heure visioconférence nous on a la
chance d'avoir une expérience citoyenne
précédente le club de foot les deux
clubs de foot pour ceux qui sont
amateurs de foot vous savez que les
clubs généralement des voisins étaient
quand même très les derby comme on
appelle ça était quand même très relevé
et bien en 2001 c'est-à-dire plus d'une
dizaine d'années avant ce processus
politique les deux clubs ont fusionné et
ça fait aujourd'hui 21 ans qui sont
fusionnés et sans problème donc cette
expérience là finalement on n'a pas été
les premiers c'est la population qui a
ouvert le terrain
sur le la population donc dès que le
processus a été lancé on a fait appel à
la population notamment sur le nom on
sait que le nom est une question
sensible et donc on a fait un appel à la
population pour nous proposer des noms
et ce travail-là on a laissé trois mois
pour que au sein des habitants il y a
cette maturation aussi intellectuelle
qu'est-ce qu'on veut mettre en avant
quel type de nom qu'est-ce que ça
recouvre on a eu plus d'une dizaine de
propositions alors des propositions
sérieuses à d'autres un peu moins voilà
on a écarté quelques-unes le les deux
Conseils Municipaux
on en retis 3 et et là françois s'en
souvient très bien puisqu'elle était
présente le 22 avril 2016 on a fait une
réunion publique réunissant les deux les
deux Conseils Municipaux les populations
des deux des deux communes Françoise
nous avait fait l'honneur d'être
présente en tant que témoignage et puis
en tant que marraine on va dire de cette
fusion et on avait le témoignage du
maire de Ploeuc l'Ermitage à
et voilà une réunion publique qui a
permis de répondre à toutes les
questions il y avait la question du
référendum qui avait été soulevé
comme nous on avait fait une ce
processus politique et que les deux
conseils municipaux à l'unanimité avait
validé on avait choisi de pas faire le
référendum c'est un grand débat en
Seigneur est une un outil très compliqué
qui peut être très dangereux voilà nous
on avait choisi cet élément là et
on a fait participer à la population
puisque lors de cette réunion publique
on l'aura présenté les trois noms je
vous passe les noms parce que c'est pas
forcément l'intérêt ici et on les a
invités à une consultation citoyenne ça
veut dire qu'on a fait un bureau de vote
dans les deux communes Saint-Brice
Saint-Étienne on a tenu par les élus des
deux conseils et on a ouvert pendant je
crois que c'était plus d'une semaine on
a ouvert des permanences pour que les
élus pour que les habitants viennent et
on a fait
la démarche également d'aller vers les
collégiens on a la chance d'avoir deux
collèges et on voulait avoir aussi leur
avis en tant que jeune du territoire qui
expérimente et c'était même eux presque
les plus grands promoteurs parce que
c'est eux qui vont avec le club de foot
dans les clubs de basket de volley qui
font déjà cette fusion là et donc on est
venu présenter au collégien on a
recueilli leur avis et tout ça nous a
permis de valider en conseil municipal
le nom de men rock donc suite à cette
langue longue expérimentation populaire
dans le sens noble du terme
la suite on parlait tout à l'heure et
nos deux présidents l’évoquaient ce
souffle qui retombe je pense que ça
c'est une première partie qui est
importante mais il y a tout le reste
notamment toute la partie accompagnement
des des services et des élus les
services parce que on modifie quand même
clairement leur mode de vie et leur mode
de fonctionnement nous on a été
accompagnés par un cabinet qui nous a
fait une démarche de diagnostic des
risques psychosociaux des fonctions
administratives donc qui a permis déjà
de voir tout ce qui bloquait de voir les
avantages et ce qui a amené à une
spécialisation des postes et surtout que
c'est ça quand même l'enjeu que les
agents se sentent pleinement dans la
commune nouvelle parce que c'est eux les
premiers promoteurs ceux qui rencontrent
la population et s'ils se sentent mal
dans la commune nouvelle on est un peu
mal après pour la suite donc voilà je
passe rapidement ce qui est intéressant
dans l'application un population après
c'est l'idée de le faire vivre cette
communion elle faut la faire vivre il
faut la l'expérimenter tous les jours et
notamment on a mis en place récemment un
comité consultatif citoyen alors d'abord
c'était sur la base du jumelage parce
qu'on a une commune qui a un passé de
jumelage très important mais qui va
s'étendre et l'idée c'est d'avoir un
comité de citoyens des anciens élus mais
également des des personnes de la
société civile comme on le dit qui vont
venir apporter leur idée qui vont venir
aussi questionner dans une un comité
libre interactif les les décisions de la
commune
et puis un dernier point que je voulais
appuyer c'est sur la marque de
territoire on parlait de logo on parlait
de nom nous on voulait aller plus loin
parce que men rock était pas connu parce
que comme une nouvelle aujourd'hui on
est la deuxième ville du pays de
Fougères donc on avait aussi un besoin
d'attractivité et donc on a créé une
Margot de territoire qu'on a appuyé à la
fois sur un label qu'on a depuis 2012 on
était le premier village en poésie avec
Montpellier en tant que vie en poésie
donc on s'appuyé sur ce label et on a
interrogé la population on leur a
demandé voilà sur men rock on est en
2022 ça fait 6 ans 7 6 ans enfin 5 ans
officiellement qu'on est comme une
nouvelle qu'est-ce que c'est pour vous
la commune nouvelle qu'est-ce que
représente mènera pour vous quels sont
les atouts les inconvénients qu'est-ce
que vous voulez qu'on mette en avant
donc on a fait un double questionnaire
sur la commune et sur l'économie
un gros travail de d'analyse on a été
accompagné par une graphiste et ça nous
a permis de créer une marionnette
territoire avec un titre
oser un bol d'air poétique parce qu'on
est dans une commune 5000 habitants en
devient une ville dans une ville dans un
milieu rural et on a cette respiration
donc une poésie artistique mais
également une poésie du quotidien et
donner un nouveau souffle c'est ce que
ce que disait nos intervenants tout à
l'heure et du coup on a tourné un film
promotionnel en 2021 avec la
participation des habitants de la de la
population des associations pour que on
crée une nouvelle identité et je pense
que le plus dur il est là quand on fait
une commune nouvelle le processus
politique s'il y a un accord ça peut
aller assez vite la préhension des la
population et la création du nouvel
entité c'est ce qui est le plus dur et
souvent on voit que les grosses communes
forcément capitalise un peu l'image
parce que c'est là où on a les services
c'est là où on a souvent les équipements
et le plus dur c'est que c'est
l'identité elle soit partagée voilà et
donc c'est vrai que si
voilà faire vivre la commune nouvelle je
pense que c'est aussi un élément
essentiel pour que pour la réussite de
cette de ce processus merci merci de ce
témoignage on va passer à une séance
d'échange et de questions on est déjà un
peu en retard donc je vous demanderai si
vous avez des questions de les faire
brève et concise et que les réponses le
soient tout autant j'ai commencé par des
questions qui arrivent par des personnes
qui ne regardent à distance une question
pour Christine Blanchet et puis bien sûr
je donnerai la parole pour Christine
Blanchet une question de Michel Lafon
qui est maire de tuer mue dans le
Calvados qui vous demande si vos maires
déléguées ont aussi une mission
d'adjoint sur une thématique
transversale première question et
concernant les indemnités des maires
délégués sont-ils sur la même base que
les adjoints
alors
les mers délégués n'ont pas de
thématiques transversales parce que tout
simplement parce que moi j'ai vécu ça au
précédent mandat j'étais merdé de la
plus petite commune et j'étais adote
éducation enfin jeunesse et puis les
trois autres maires déléguées avaient
aussi ses missions transversales et
enfin à mon sens ça ne fonctionnait pas
très bien
parce que dont on n'avait pas le temps
de faire les deux de toute façon déjà et
puis en plus on avait tendance
inconsciemment à privilégier sa commune
déléguée sur la politique en question
donc ça on l'a partagé aussi pendant la
campagne électorale de dire est-ce qu'on
met une thématique ou est-ce que le ceci
dit non mer délégué ont des appétences
plus ou moins importantes sur certaines
thématiques donc viennent apporter
évidemment leur compétences
mais ils ont vraiment ce rôle d'adjointe
territoire donc de proximité de faire
remonter les besoins d'en être les
garants
et puis au niveau des indemnités ils ont
exactement les mêmes indemnités ce sont
des adjoints au même titre que les
adjoints de poules
je voudrais ajouter qu'il y en a pas un
au dessus de l'autre en fait je sais pas
si on peut dire ça comme ça mais dans la
hiérarchie des élus
je vais vous signale que Madame Aurélie
Gigan ou guigan je ne sais pas mère de
Saint-Sauveur village est très
intéressant pour mener une démarche de
projet de territoire tel que vous l'avez
présenté madame Blanchet donc elle
voulait entrer en contact avec vous et
recevoir le cahier des charges sur
lequel vous êtes appuyé elle va quitter
la conférence mais on vous donnera son
contact
pour le maire de Jugon-les-Lacs nous
demande toujours Michel Lafont maire de
tuer mu est-ce que vous avez conservé
les mers délégués
donc du coup comme je le disais cette
commune nouvelle c'est sur deux communes
dans les statues en effet
il y a toujours cette notion de commune
déléguée
donc qui dit commune déléguée dit aussi
deux personnes
identifiées comme mère délégué mais là
gestion de la commune se fait comme une
commune à part entière c'est purement
administratif et pour tout vous dire on
nous sommes aujourd'hui en rénovation de
la de la mairie il est fort probable que
une fois qu'elle sera terminée
on se posera la question de de la
suppression de cette notion de commune
déléguée mais aujourd'hui
dans les strates de communes nouvelles
il y a il faut être vigilant notamment
au nombre de communes et au nombre
d'habitants nous on est que deux
communes même si je le disais
historiquement il y avait déjà trois
communes mais et ça ne fait que 2500
habitants et entre les trois bourses il
y a que trois kilomètres donc
[Musique]
nous avons une commune nouvelle aussi
pas très loin de chez nous ou ils sont 5
ou 6 communes avec des distances
beaucoup plus importantes entre les
Bours la notion de communes déléguée
prend peut-être un peu plus de sens
une réaction très rapide effectivement
tout est à faire je pense aussi de
superficie lorsque et de regroupement si
vous avez deux communes qui sont
groupées c'est vrai que
à une proche distance ça peut être
problématique de dire on a un maire
délégué par commune délégué ça complique
les choses par contre lorsqu'on est sur
un groupement plus important nous c'est
15 communes déléguées c'est un
territoire de 26000 hectares
dans les mots je j'ai pas mal de
collègues du Maine-et-Loire qui sont là
c'est le même problématique le maire
délégué c'est quand même le relais local
maintenant se posera certainement la
question à terme
je vois on a des on a un maire délégué
pour une commune de 52 habitants c'était
la plus petite commune on l'a conservé
voilà on voit bien que c'est un peu
compliqué pour animer parce que pour
faire vivre la commune nouvelle on a
gardé nous ce qu'on appelle les conseils
communaux qui sont en fait des conseils
de quartier avec des élus mais aussi des
habitants et des associations et pour
vivre faire vivre quand vous les 52
habitants c'est un peu compliqué par
contre ça a du sens à ce que vous avez
mis l'habitants et que vous êtes situé à
7 8 km de la commune centre d'avoir un
relais bon et puis accessoirement quand
vous quand vos calculez aussi avec
l'enveloppe des indemnités vous savez
que l'enveloppe des maires déléguées
n'est pas pris sur l'enveloppe des
adjoints donc comme vous êtes limité
avec le nombre d'adjoints par rapport au
nombre d'élus comme vous le savez bah ça
peut être un moyen de trouver un
équilibre mais au-delà de ça ça se pose
la question aussi des fois de
l'efficacité parce que mettre des mères
délégués pour le plaisir de mettre des
mers délégués chez nous ils sont
nécessairement président d'une
commission transversale c'est
obligatoire comme ça il raisonne pas
trop ma petite commune déléguée et mon
trottoir
est-ce qu'il y a des questions dans la
salle ou des remarques ou des
interventions sur cette question des
communes déléguées monsieur ici
alors me regarde je le redis comprenez
le message Olivier de cogniou je suis
maire de Sainte-Marie-sur-Mer en
Seine-Maritime à la fois comme une
rurale électorale et se pose la question
je crois des de l'identité des villages
finalement qui constituent la commune
nouvelle et finalement quel est
l'intérêt de créer des mers délégués par
rapport à conserver d'identité des
villages très souvent c'est au niveau
des habitants c'est ça ce qui est
important c'est de le nom du village et
l'institution administrative c'est autre
chose
qui veut répondre là dessus
ou sur la question des mers délégués un
peu en général d'ailleurs
j'en profite pour saluer l'arrivée
Jean-Marc Vasse qui nous a qui nous a
rejoint maire de terre Decaux et qui est
ma référent des communes nouvelle à la
MF donc qui qu'au président toute cette
séance avec nous monsieur Valls bonjour
à tous madame c'est natrice et
dessinateur qui sont ici je salue le
président pélissaire également excusé
vraiment ce retard mais vous savez que
les joies de la SNCF nous réserve
parfois quelques surprises
juste pour le collègue
il y a un mot qui a été prononcé qui est
le mot village
je crois que les mots ont du sens et il
est important de réaffirmer la
distinction entre la commune déléguée
qui est un machin technocratique et le
village qui est une communauté d'hommes
et de femmes qui vivent ensemble qui
sont faits comme on le disait dans le
manifeste que nous avions produit à la
MF fait de chair et de pierre et il faut
effectivement
identifier cela et moi pour ma part qui
suit maire d'une commune nouvelle
composée de 7 communes déléguées nous
avons par exemple dans les mots non pas
par les Conseils communal mais de
conseils de village le conseil de chacun
des 6 villages et le conseil de Bourg
nous avons maintenu les mers délégués
parce que nous pensons que
l'identification d'une personne dans le
village est essentiel c'est la porte
d'entrée c'est la alors ils ont tous une
fonction transverse dans la commune
nouvelle parce que nous gérons la
commune nouvelle ensemble mais il
n'empêche que vis-à-vis des habitants
c'est important
et le président Larcher j'ai pas eu la
chance de l'écouter tout à l'heure
m'avait dit quand il était venu en
Seine-Maritime les collègues s'en
souviennent
nous avais dit mais il faudra 25 ans
donc il faut qu'on accompagne cette
transition pour que les générations
après les générations s'habitue à une
nouvelle institution qui est la commune
nouvelle sans oublier le village qui est
leur village de proximité leur village
de coeur etc et il faut effectivement ça
a été dit tout à l'heure par notre
collègue de men rock associé les jeunes
les plus jeunes les collégiens se sont
eux dans les équipes de foot
effectivement dans les écoles que qui
feront effectivement cette identité
commune donc il faut prendre son temps
me semble-t-il mais ça dépend des
circonstances
les choses ne sont pas les mêmes quand
on a deux communes qui sont l'une à côté
de l'autre quand on a 12 ou 15 communes
où on est 7 les surfaces sont pas les
mêmes enfin bref il faut à chaque fois
s'adapter aux circonstances me
semble-t-il
sur ce même sujet non c'est pas le bon
je pense
en écho à ce que l'on a dit à deux
reprises on a entendu
le mot de service et collaborateur c'est
à dire on voit bien qu'il y a un enjeu
d'association de la population mais si
on associe pas les services l'exercice
est compliqué parce que parfois il y a
des peurs j'ai l'exemple d'une commune
nouvelle qui a raté simplement parce
qu'il y a un DGS qui avait peur de ce
qu'elle allait devenir donc ça c'est
important ensuite on a parlé de voulait
bien dit de l'exigence
du continuum d'entretien de l'amitié de
la nécessité de s'apprivoiser c'est pas
parce que la commune nouvelle est faite
que on a créé une famille très unie
c'est un peu la logique de la famille
recomposée où on a chacun notre histoire
est en même temps doit se construire un
chemin et qu'il faut effectivement
veiller
à tisser un lien qui fait qu'à un moment
on sera plus simplement
une addition à regroupement d'identité
particulière mais on sera on sera autre
chose et puis le nom et l'identité alors
je salue tout particulièrement les élus
du Pays de Fougères qui sont là ils sont
deux Thomas janvier de men rock et Marc
de Gouvion-Saint-Cyr
des portes du coq c'est un territoire de
granit alors la Bretagne déjà vous savez
il y a une identité alors dans le pays
de Fougères c'est puisse ensuite et que
le nom est quelque chose d'essentiel ça
peut aussi faire capoter la commune
nouvelle ou faire balayer le maire on
l'a dit il y a de manière de faire il y
a des élus qui commencent par se mettre
d'accord sur le nom
d'autres qui disent on parle pas de ça
ça va être compliqué on va voir comment
ça va murer dans ma modesse expérience
de création de comme une nouvelle c'est
le deuxième scénario qu'on avait choisi
mais l'identité est importante on a vu
vous l'avez dit Monsieur le Maire des
élus inventés à non nouveau neutre
justement pour qu'il y ait aucune
commune qu'elle est de prévaloir et donc
on a perdu son identité comme on
perdrait son nom de famille et les gens
ils ont perdu cet attachement et vous
vous avez su dans le pays de Fougères
trouver un nom qui a du sens et c'est la
même chose pour ma collègue derrière
alors c'est un nom vous allez croire que
les Bretons ce qu'on est tous de la même
famille ce Christelle brocelier elle
émet d'une commune nouvelle qui est
écrit qui s'appelle Ménil rock
et qui est dans la Bretagne Romantique
la mienne ne s'appelle pas Châteaugiron
rock elle a acheté
les élus de campagne merci je prends une
dernière question mais vraiment très
brève on est en retard et on va on va
faire conclure cette séquence par Paul
carrer donc allez-y une petite question
très rapidement par rapport à la place
des maires délégués parce que Nicolas
chéri je suis mère délégué de
Saint-Martin-du-Bois au sein de ce grand
ange ou bleu dans le 49 je suis une
petite commune déléguée de 1100 dans une
commune de 18500 et je voulais
réaffirmer la position du maire délégué
même si je trouve que le MIR délégué je
sais pas si c'est le terme qui convient
bien parce que dans l'esprit des gens le
maire délégué c'est un sous-mer voilà je
vous le dis comme je le ressens auprès
des gens alors qu'on a un travail qui
est vraiment complet je suis
accessoirement en même temps adjoint au
sport des 15 communes qui vont avec et
tout à l'heure quand j'entendais qu'on
faisait des missions séparées entre les
deux moi c'est pas vrai que ce soit ma
commune délayer ou la commune de ces
grands Anjou bleu je suis à 100% et je
pense qu'il faudrait affirmer la place
du maire délégué dans les communes
nouvelle peut-être qu'on a un nouveau
nom j'en sais rien mais surtout pour des
gens moi je suis actif et si on veut
pouvoir faire le tout et bien le faire
et auprès des gens c'est très important
de mettre en valeur ce poste là puisque
aujourd'hui je pense que il est pas
toujours bien compris par les habitants
bon très rapidement vous poser vous
poser un vrai sujet c'est le statut du
maire délégué ce n'est pas vraiment
prévu dans la loi c'est un maire mais
avec des prérogatives moins importantes
ce qui induit des confusions et aimer
parfois le maire délégué en citation
délicate moi je suis persuadé qu'il est
important qu'il a un rôle important
maintenant il faut qu'il a un vrai
statut
très bien alors on peut pas prendre
toutes les questions donc j'ai quelques
questions qui me sont arrivées on ne
pourra pas y répondre mais on y répondra
par la suite les services de la MF il
répondront ou s'il y a des demandes de
contact entre élus bien sûr on les on
les honorera je vais demander à Monsieur
Carrera Paul carrer pardon maire de
morsang-la-nouvelle de faire une petite
synthèse une petite conclusion de cette
première séquence qu'est-ce que vous en
avez retiré il y a beaucoup d'exemples
et beaucoup de d'expérience très
passionnantes
oui bonjour à tous vous m'entendez tout
à fait très bien bon ben écoutez ça a
été effectivement très intéressant comme
comme salé depuis quelques mois ou
quelques années puisque en réunit assez
régulièrement les maires des communes
nouvelles pour faire synthèse un peu de
l'histoire et de l'historique de
création ou de difficultés aussi des
différentes communes nouvelles
constituées ce matin on a bel exemple
concret qu'il n'y a pas une une façon de
faire mais qui en a autant que de
communes nouvelles créées dans la mesure
où chacun dans un contexte particulier
dans un périmètre particulier a besoin
de travailler de faire valider un projet
et d'avancer sur la mise en place du
projet de territoire ce qui est
intéressant et je reprendrai la formule
d'un des mers qui a témoigné ce matin
c'est créer animé
créer une commune nouvelle mais il y a
ceux qui l'ont fait un petit peu forceps
il y a ceux qui l'ont fait en prenant le
temps de créer un projet de territoire
discuter et d'organiser un petit peu le
nouveau périmètre on se rend compte
surtout qu'il faut vraiment pas le
déconnecter de la réalité des citoyens
puisque ceux qui l'ont fait un petit peu
sans considérer en surtout pas souvent
été réélu en 2020 on en a eu un exemple
ce matin mais effectivement on se rend
compte que la part des citoyens elle est
très importante dans la construction
dans l'identité à créer et dans la vie
de notre commune nouvelle alors moi je
suis sur un territoire les Landes alors
j'en profite pour saluer Eric et rouge
qui est sale Médicis puisqu'on est deux
landais ce matin je pense
on est dans on est dans un département
où il y a deux comme une nouvelle c'est
pas le cas de chez Philippe ou de chez
Jean-Marc que je salue également où il y
a beaucoup plus de communes nouvelles on
a un département où la commune nouvelle
n'a pas encore fait n'a pas fait
sensation je dirais mais on est en train
malgré tout par l'exemple les deux
maires de communes nouvelles et les
équipes communales de mon entrée
bénéficience dans le contexte que
viendraper Philippe c'est-à-dire le
contexte de crise le contexte de
difficulté territoriale le contexte de
combat pour un regroupement pédagogique
ou le contexte économique compliqué mais
on montre que on tient bon et que les
petits villages qui composent nos
communes nouvelles et bien en toute leur
part à la décision et bénéficient de
l'apport de la commune centre je crois
qu'il faut effectivement
travailler le projet de territoire c'est
ce qu'on dit les quatre les quatre
personnes qui ont communiqué jusqu'à
maintenant parce que c'est quand même ça
l'alpha et l'oméga on s'est beaucoup
focalisé sur le nom du de la commune
nouvelle qui est un postulat de départ
souvent certains imposent le discute on
se rend compte qu'il faut que les gens
se l'approprient sans frustrer les
villages originels sans frustré
d'identité des villages Originels on a
parlé de l'importance des maires
délégués moi je crois que ça fait partie
de l'acceptation des villages le fait
d'avoir ces maires délégués de leur
donner des missions alors
moi j'ai la chance peut-être sur ma
commune nouvelle que les maires délégués
ne sentent pas dévalorisés par rapport
au maire que je suis ils ont une
continuation de leur mission un des
trois maires délégués des quatre
villages
et le même que le coup d'avant deux ont
été renouvelés et on se rend compte de
la tâchement des villageois à leur mère
délégué que nous considérons comme
toujours le maire du village concerné et
qui garde bon nombre de ses attributions
et qui aux yeux de la population n'a pas
été dévalorisé je crois que ça aussi
c'est très important
et puis après il faut trouver la place
dans l'intercommunalité certains parler
d'intercommunalité très importante nous
on est une communauté de communes de six
communes on était neuf on est plus que 6
donc imaginez la difficulté pour les
communes qui sont engagées sur notre
petite communauté de communes de dix
mille habitants quand ils voient une
commune nouvelle de 6200 habitants
arrivés ça a modifié certaines relations
enfin où ça peut les modifier et donc il
faut que la commune nouvelle prenne
place dans cette interco et c'est aussi
une pour les plus petits villages qui
s'agrègent de voir que leurs paroles est
peut-être entendu différemment que les
outils sont différents et donc il y a
une vraie valeur ajoutée puis j'ai en
terminerai par là vous avez parlé de
moments difficiles sur les communes
Philippe a parlé des perroquets
d'incendie on a eu différentes périodes
compliquées on se rend compte
effectivement et la population s'en rend
compte très vite
que la commune nouvelle est une vraie
valeur ajoutée par rapport à des moments
de critiques à des moments difficiles
alors moi je fais partie de ceux qui
n'ont pas fait de référendum puisqu'on a
créé notre commune nouvelle au 1er
janvier 2019 et qu'après il y a eu un
effet un référendum de fées c'est les
élections municipales et on s'est rendu
compte que dans l'année d'installation
préalable aux élections municipales on a
connu ce référendum puisque on avait une
une refonte complète des listes et on
avait trois des quatre mers qui arrêtés
et ça a été l'opportunité d'avoir
plusieurs listes je l'ai déjà expliqué
dans le cadre des élections 2020 et la
population a largement validé le projet
de commune nouvelle puisque nous
portions avec une liste ce projet à
développer et les deux autres c'était
assez frontalement opposé à ce projet de
commune nouvelle et on a vu la
validation de l'ensemble des citoyens
puisque c'est plus de 72 ou 113% qui
vont valider dès le premier tour et
l'attachement déjà ce projet de commune
nouvelle donc je crois que la population
sur intègre puisque nous l'avions
enterré deux ans avant la signature de
la commune nouvelle peu appréhender
peut s'associer et intégrer totalement
le principe d'une commune nouvelle c'est
une commune nouvelle que nous avions
fondée sur le regroupement pédagogique
et le travail éducatif et sur la mise en
place et la création d'une réservation
nationale naturelle et donc quand il a
de beau et de grands projets apportés
sur un territoire je pense que la
population ne mesure donc on a un
encouragement à continuer à porter sur
nos territoires effectivement la covid
de nos a pas aidés dans le cadre du
développement des communes nouvelles
je ne parlerai pas du rapport parce que
d'autres en parleront après et Philippe
en a parlé au préalable je pense que
nous imposer de façon assez arithmétique
et cadencée ses créations de communes
nouvelles et de comité ne portera pas
ses fruits ce qui est important c'est
que nous élu locaux de proximité soyons
en mesure de la compagnie les projets
portés ou souhaité par d'autres ou
d'expliquer les outils à d'autres élus
locaux qui peuvent pour des raisons
diverses et variées avoir envie de
devenir essayer la commune nouvelle donc
il faut qu'on reprenne notre bâton de
pèlerin je dirais pour aller expliquer à
ceux qui le souhaitent mais les
bénéfices que mais surtout les bénéfices
de la mise en place d'une commune
nouvelle et les écueils que l'on peut
rencontrer à sa création voilà merci
merci Monsieur le Maire écoutez on va
passer donc à la deuxième séquence de ce
de cette matinée donc en parler un peu
d'avenir quelle nouvelle élan comment
relancer le mouvement des communes
nouvelles et pour
introduire ces débats on va avoir deux
temps on va d'abord donner la parole à
Jacques pelissa qui va nous donner un
certain nombre d'éléments sur y compris
les raisons pour lesquelles il a mis en
avant cette loi en 2015 en 2013 2015 et
puis ensuite on écoutera Vincent Bel qui
nous livrera les conclusions du 2e
panorama des communes nouvelle et puis
ensuite de nouveau une table ronde un
débat avec des témoignages d'élus et la
parole à la salle
Jacques Mélissa donc vous êtes président
d'honneur de l'AMF ancien président de
l'association et vous avez porté avec
Christine Pirès bonne le projet de loi
et la proposition de loi pardon qui a
permis cette explosion des communes
nouvelles à partir de 2015 alors
pouvez-vous nous raconter un peu
pourquoi cette initiative a été prise et
puis quelle vision vous avez de l'avenir
des communes nouvelles
merci à vous monsieur le marc
tout d'abord madame la sénatrice
présidente de la négation aux
collectivités locales et la
décentralisation mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs
de vous-même dans vos responsabilités
monsieur le marc ici ma présence me
rajeunit elle m'a raginnie fortement
parce que je vois des visages amis dans
la salle je vois surtout attribu une
frangeatelle que j'ai connu
président des maires d'Ille-et-Vilaine
vice-président de la MF c'était un temps
en plus ancien qu'aujourd'hui bien sûr
en 93 en 2003 2013 et c'était l'année de
gestation des communes nouvelles quelle
était la situation à l'époque bien tout
d'abord moi j'avais constaté avec les
différentes visites que j'ai fait dans
les départements pour vous assemblée
générale de mer beaucoup de mères qui me
disaient on sent une désinfection par
rapport à la chose communale on sent que
les maires les adjoints au fil des
années qui passent se désintéresse de ce
qui se déroule dans la commune et c'est
vrai que en 2014
60 communes c'est important 60 communes
de France n'ont pas eu le moindre
candidat au premier tour des élections
municipales ça continue d'ailleurs
puisque en 2020 le juge va intéresser il
y a 18000 communes c'est à dire 52% des
communes actuelles ont eu autant de
postes à pouvoir que de candidats donc
il y a pas de concurrence il y a pas eu
d'émulation il y avait uniquement une
ajustement des postes à pouvoir sur les
candidats qui se manifestent qui se
manifestaient donc un défi démocratique
réel deuxième chose un déficit financier
vous en souvenez sûrement mais la loi de
programmation de finances des finances
publiques pour la période 2012-2017
prévoyait une baisse de 11 milliards
d'euros de dotation d'État 11 milliards
pour l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales c'était considérable et
cette baisse était à la fois progressive
mais définitive c'est-à-dire quand vous
allez retiré une année une certaine
somme sur le DGF c'était la somme
aggravée l'année suivante qui imposaient
à vous donc des visites financiers puis
un troisième des visites que
j'appellerais les visites juridiques si
je puis dire parce que vous aviez une
implication très forte une imbrication
une imbrication très forte entre les
compétences communales restantes et
compétences communautaires des
intercommunalités et parfois c'est
imbrication se transforma en véritable
imbroglio on s'appuient
qui faisait quoi et qui était
responsable de quoi
les phases à cela il y avait un outil
qui existait il était issu de la loi RCT
de 2000 était la commune nouvelle
première génération si je puis dire mais
cette commune nouvelle première
génération était inaboutie avec des
défaillances fortes sur le plan
financier et sur le plan juridique alors
sur le plan financier sur plan jeudi moi
j'ai tout de suite essayé de trouver des
solutions en comptant les ministres de
l'époque ministre également Hollande qui
était à l'époque même le branchu
et c'est vrai que j'ai eu une attente
une écoute de leur part tout à fait
intéressante et dès la loi de finances
pour 2014 nous avons réussi à faire
passer un amendement qui prévoyait la
stabilité du DGS la sévité de la DGS
pour les communes nouvelles toutes les
communes toutes les collectivités
locales voyez leur DGF diminué et que
une nouvelle était préservées il y avait
une stabilité de leur DGF et on va
ensuite après la loi du mars 2015 on
aura une augmentation de 5% pour des
communes nouvelles bref ce plan
financier a trouvé une solution mais il
fallait au-delà il fallait la surplomb
juridique et ce plan institutionnel il
me passait important que les communes
historiques c'est le mot maintenant
qu'on leur attache reste des lieux de
proximité des lieux c'était très bien
dit par période ici les lieux de
proximité des lieux d'identité
d'identité les lieux solidarité et sa
raison pour laquelle on s'est mis à
l'oeuvre pour réfléchir à ce que pouvait
être une nouvelle alors là on arrive à
quelques semaines avant le congrès des
maires de France de 2013
et beaucoup de mes collègues me disent
ne parle pas des communes nouvelles
c'est casse-gueule expression dans le
texte
beaucoup de membres du bureau quelques
associations spécifiques spécifiques des
vieux coups me disent on parle pas des
nouvelles et la tribune sont les
biens de France du congrès de France
comme aujourd'hui je me suis dit en
conscience à ce que j'en parle parce
qu'ils en parle pas
et j'en ai parlé et mes propos pouvaient
susciter soit des sifflements soit des
applaudissements se furent des
applaudissements et on s'est mis à la à
l'oeuvre avec la MF avec les services
d'AMF pour une épopée parlementaire
fabuleuse et rapide avec Magic System
Georges il présente avec le directeur
général l'AMF qui était Monsieur Michel
Bezeau on a rédigé la loi
j'ai déposé la loi la proposition de loi
au début de l'année 2014 et cette loi eu
un cheminement intéressant puisque le
gouvernement a déclaré l'urgence pour
les non parlementaires j'explique
déclaré d'urgence c'est à dire qu'il n'y
a qu'une seule lecture assemblée une
structure au Sénat donc l'urgence a été
déclaré une lecture au Sénat assemblée
d'abord au Sénat ensuite vote unanime
parce qu'il y avait un consensus
politique
intéressant sur ce texte et la loi a été
promulguée le 16 mars 2015 et après
cette loi promulguée 2016 mars 2015 mais
il a fallu la faire vivre il a fallu
faire vivre la loi et là je tiens à
remercier tous ceux qui ont été les
portes paroles de cette loi de son
intérêt du fait qu'elle préservait à la
fois l'identité des communes mais
qu'elle permettait de regrouper les
moyens regrouper les moyens financiers
regrouper les moyens humains aussi bien
les élus que les fonctionnaires
regrouper les moyens techniques ça a été
évoqué par un collègue tout à l'heure et
se regroupement était donc une source
extrêmement importante de vitalité des
communes nouvelles
avec un résultat intéressant je vous
donne le chiffre mais je dois quand même
par coeur vous avez eu
767 communes nouvelles qui ont été créés
de 2016 à 2018 alors que avec la commune
nouvelle première génération si je puis
dire
issue de la loi du de décembre 2010 il y
en a vu que 20 20 entre 2010 et 2015
767 pour la période récente et vous êtes
les acteurs chers collègues de cette
réussite
et puis je suis dans quel temps elles
sont on a eu une période de pause que
nous vivons encore aujourd'hui il faut
expliquer rapidement vous avez eu bien
sûr la loi qui prévoyait que il n'y
avait aucune création de communes
nouvelles de l'année qui précédait les
élections municipales donc 2019 était
gelée ensuite on a eu la période de la
covid 2020 et puis ensuite la période de
l'année post électorale ou aux équipes
mises en place ont souvent des
difficultés des projets à concevoir des
responsabilités à partager bref pour le
moment le rebond nouveau dès qu'une
nouvelle n'est pas encore intervenues et
ces raisons pour laquelle nous sommes
réunis avec
les trois positions qui vont être formés
tout à l'heure par professeur Aubel ici
présent qui est en France l'un des
professeurs des universités spécialisés
avec une nouvelle les chroniques et les
livres qu'il a édité qu'il a écrit
montre ses compétences en matière je
vais lui laisser la parole en quelques
instants il y a eu des propositions
aussi faites par par l'hygia c'est
l'inspection générale administration un
rapport qui vient de sortir je crois que
du 21 septembre
m'appesanterais pas sauf sur un point le
premier la première proposition déjà qui
dit dans chaque département il faut
faire un schéma
départemental des communes nouvelles il
faut un document d'orientation
territoriale ils sont aux antipodes aux
antipodes de l'idée que nous avons eu
que nous avons fait prospérer que
j'avais conçu initialement aux Ant de
cette idée de liberté c'était très bien
dit de la part David il est l'heure la
liberté sur un triple registre liberté
de décider une comme une nouvelle ou pas
est-ce qu'on est d'accord pour passer à
une commune nouvelle liberté du choix du
territoire avec qui faisons-nous cette
commune nouvelle sur quelle zone
géographique puis liberté aussi de cette
approche en termes de seuil la loi ne
prévoit pas la loi que que j'ai à
l'époque porté ne prévoit pas de seuil
elle ne prévoit pas de schéma
prescriptif de prévoir d'un sens
décisionnaire la décision c'est nous qui
apprenons apprenons sur le choix sur le
périmètre et sur les modalités de
fonctionnement c'était très clair et
très net et je vous remercie tous les
intervenants notables ronde précédente
ont montré une diversité d'organisations
avec des rôles différents des communes
nouvelles des communes déléguées des
maires déléguées des responsabilités
adaptées au territoire parce que chers
collègues c'est vous les maires nous les
mers mais dans votre confrérie si je
puis dire parce que j'ai été maire
pendant 31 ans c'est nous qui
connaissons les territoires c'est nous
qui avons l'intelligence des situations
c'est nous effectivement qui pouvons
décider la réorganisation territoriale
grâce à cet outil nouveau que sont comme
une nouvelle alors il faut faire vivre
ces communes et je termine en vous
disant vous avez été chers collègues des
novateurs vous avez été des pionniers
vous avez expérimenté vous avez porté
votre expérimentation qui a souvent eu
un effet contagieux vous avez été
contagieux dans votre conviction et bien
pour les semaines qui viennent pour les
mois qui viennent pour les années qui
viennent soyez des ambassadeurs
convaincus des communes nouvelles soyez
des avocats
raisonner mais aussi passionné de cet
outil qui nous est commun que nous avons
créé ensemble et comme une nouvelle
merci
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président et vous
donnerez peut-être votre votre avis plus
tard dans le débat sur les moyens qui
peuvent être utilisés pour relancer le
mouvement sur ce sujet je donne
maintenant la parole à Vincent Aubel
donc qui a été annoncé par Jacques
Pélissard lui-même professeur des
universités associées école d'Urbanisme
de Paris Université Gustave Eiffel vous
allez nous présenter votre deuxième
panorama des communes nouvelles le
premier je crois est paru en 2019
bien voilà maintenant venu le temps du
deuxième tome je vous laisse en
présenter en une dizaine de minutes les
enseignements
mesdames messieurs donc je vais essayer
de vous présenter de façon synthétique
le deuxième tome donc du panorama des
communes nouvelles donc Gérard Larcher
indiqué dans son propos introductif que
vous l'aviez ce matin en exclusivité
mondiale
donc j'ai partir loin dans le monde je
vais commencer par partir loin dans le
monde mais je vous rassure dans 30
secondes dans 30 secondes maximum je
vais réatérire sur les communes
nouvelles loin dans le monde c'est de
vous emmener c'est dans un peuple de la
haute Amazonie en Bolivie le ce qu'on
appelle le peuple qui s'appelle le
peuple des achua et en fait qu'un pub
qui a été étudié par beaucoup
d'ethnologues
et en fait c'est une discussion entre
deux ethnologues et un des deux
ethnologues se plaignait auprès d'un de
ses confrères alors qu'il vivait avec ce
peuple depuis une dizaine d'années il
disait mais je comprends pas quand je me
réveille le matin en fait ils sont
partis chasser ils sont partis cueillir
ils sont partis péchés ils sont partis
aller chercher les feuilles pour
construire les toitures et je ne
comprends pas pourquoi ils m'ont pas
informé alors qu'ils vivaient avec eux
au quotidien il parlait leur langue etc
etc en fait son collègue lui dit et
j'arrive aux communes nouvelles il lui
dit en fait
pourquoi t'es pas informé c'est parce
que tu raisonnes par l'esprit de ce
qu'on appelle l'esprit de symétrisation
et en fait l'esprit de symétrisation
c'est en fait quand on raisonne avec des
catégories mentales qui sont absolument
pas adaptés à la situation
et là on retrouve exactement la
problématique des communes nouvelles
c'est-à-dire que les communes nouvelles
c'est quoi
les communes nouvelles sont pas des
chiffres sont pas des stocks sont pas
des quantités mais les communes
nouvelles pour ceux qui les ont pratiqué
ce sont des singularités les communes
nouvelles c'est l'implicite les communes
nouvelles ce sont des sous-entendus des
communes nouvelles se sont des regards
les communes nouvelles ce sont des
engueulades des communes nouvelles ce
sont des repas bref les communes
nouvelles c'est tout d'abord et avant
tout une affaire de chair une affaire
d'intimes et une affaire de désir c'est
une affaire de vivant et que pour
comprendre les communes nouvelles il
faut prendre cette perspective sinon on
ne comprend rien aux communes nouvelles
alors pour l'universitaire que je suis
vous présenter ce rapport je voudrais
tout d'abord remercier et c'est vraiment
extrêmement sincère l'Association des
maires de France de m'avoir donné cette
possibilité
ce qui demande que cette association qui
assure la promotion de la commune dans
toutes ces étendues qu'elle soit
nouvelle ou pas est un creuset
finalement aussi de réflexion pour faire
avancer le débat j'espère être à la
hauteur de celui-ci et nous pas tomber
justement dans les de procéder par
esprit de symétrisation par catégorie
qui ne serait pas adapté et donc ce
rapport en fait
de quoi se compose-t-il en réalité ce
qu'on compose de deux parties
une première partie qui comporte deux
sous parties ça c'est le juriste qui
vous parle désolé mais on soigne je me
soigne sachant que la première partie
est un bilan quantitatif donc sur les
communes nouvelles donc vous trouverez
la plus petite à la plus grande c'est le
cas le plus grand nombre de communes
enfin etc vous retrouverez plein de
chiffres et si vous en voulez d'autres
ayant reconstitué avec les services
Adobe de la MF les bases de données il y
a pas de problème mais ce que je trouve
intéressant là-dedans plutôt que de
gloser finalement il y a que un peu de
communes nouvelles qui comporte un grand
nombre de communes ou la taille des
communes nouvelles est trop petite moi
il y a une citation de Michel Serres que
j'aime bien un ordre enraciné qui fait
enraciner dans les terroirs et quand on
l'a interrogé sur son identité donc il
déclinait un certain nombre de
caractéristiques son âge son sexe enfin
etc etc et résumer ça par une magnifique
formule qu'on pourrait prendre pour les
communes nouvelles et c'est ce que vous
retrouverez dans cette analyse
quantitative
je suis je voilà tout je suis la somme
de mes appartenances effectivement les
communes nouvelles c'est la somme de
toutes ces appartenances de toutes ces
diversités la deuxième chose dans cette
enfin la deuxième sous-partie la
première partie c'est que vous trouverez
une tentative d'analyse pour essayer de
comprendre la géographie des communes
nouvelles parce qu'il est vrai que cette
géographie c'est à titre principal
concentré sur l'ouest de la France et en
fait vous verrez quand on quand on
superpose les cartes des calques en fait
la géographie des communes nouvelles
elle est pas sans lien avec la
géographie de l'intercommunalité en 1904
en 1993 94 95 puisque j'ai reconstitué
toutes ces cartes là qui n'existaient
nulle part donc vous verrez vous
superposerez ces calques vous verrez que
dans cette géographie il y a beaucoup de
choses à voir avec le vote donc sur le
vote notamment sur des questions de
référendum je vais vite parce que j'ai
10 minutes et sinon Franck va me dire de
d'arrêter
ont beaucoup de choses à voir avec la
superficie des communes etc etc vous
retrouvez un certain nombre
d'indicateurs ce qu'il faut en retenir
c'est que le pont auquel j'aboutis c'est
qu'on a effectivement des superpositions
qui marchent assez bien pour autant je
n'en tiens aucune théorie de la commune
nouvelle mais ça répond plus c'est un
phénomène culturel un phénomène culturel
la deuxième partie du rapport donc c'est
un ensemble de 14 propositions donc
c'est peut-être là on va arriver au
deuxième souffle des communes nouvelles
et avec le souci dans ses propositions
d'avoir été des propositions qui collent
qui ne soient pas en surplomb mais qui
partent du terrain parce que moi je suis
pas élu j'adore les élus et donc c'est à
force de vivre avec des élus forcément
vous écoutez et il y a des propositions
qui peuvent aussi bien concerner des
questions de finance des questions
d'intercommunalité des questions de
Régine indemnités de communes délégués
bref je vais pas tout vous les énoncer
je voudrais simplement retenir et en
ayant eu le souci dans chacune de ces
propositions d'aller au bout du
raisonnement si il s'agit pas uniquement
dénoncer une vérité mais de dire si on
suit cette proposition comment on
pourrait modifier la loi et dans quel
sens on pourrait y arriver donc vous
verrez vous lirez je voudrais simplement
retenir trois points essentiels dans
dans ses propositions il y a du général
quoique et du plus particulier
le premier point c'est de rappeler vous
l'avez dit mais je ne cesserai aussi de
m'associer à cette parole c'est que la
commune nouvelle c'est d'abord et avant
tout et peut-être juste ça c'est un acte
de liberté c'est pas autre chose la
commune nouvelle c'est un acte de
liberté et qu'effectivement elle ne
serait s'imposer et que comme elle ne
serait s'imposer c'est pas la peine
d'inventer des commissions ça sert
strictement à rien puisque l'essence de
la commune nouvelle elle vient de la
chair des élus qu'on vit de faire ou de
ne pas faire ou de rien à faire parce
qu'il y a pas de systématisme de commune
nouvelle premier point et que dans cet
acte de liberté je tiens quand même à
dire que les communes nouvelles
effectivement on peut constater que la
majorité des communes nouvelles ne
comporte que deux communes mais faut-il
que je vous rappelle que les communes
nouvelles et vous en êtes le témoignage
elles évoluent si je regarde les
nouvelles communes nouvelles ce qu'on
appelle les nouvelles communes nouvelles
moi j'aime pas le terme de surfusion
parce que ça ne correspond absolument
pas ce que c'est la commune nouvelle les
nouvelles communes nouvelles ce sont des
communes nouvelles qui ont été créées et
j'ai Philippe Chalopin qui est à côté de
moi il voit très très bien ce que ce que
je veux dire et qui ont recréé une
commune nouvelle avec des communes qui
n'appartenaient pas une commune nouvelle
il y en a 40 c'est énorme quand on y
pense 40 nouvelles communes nouvelles et
que donc cette liberté elle est au cœur
du processus d'évolution et que donc ce
qui est intéressant dans cette liberté
c'est là où je prends une position de
sur plan puisque le président de Larcher
a parlé une nouvelle loi
décentralisation c'est qu'en réalité
peut-être un jour mais j'espère le plus
rapidement possible qu'on comprendra que
cette histoire de commune nouvelle
certes qui ne concerne que ktmi pour
cent des communes françaises mais en
réalité c'est la première fois qu'on a
une véritable décentralisation c'est à
dire où ce sont les élus qui la mettent
en œuvre et ça ne vient pas du haut et
on replace chacun sa place puisqu'en
fait on a un état on a besoin d'un état
mais un état non pas qui encadre toutes
les dispositions qui fixent des bornes à
l'intérieur desquels les élus doivent
évoluer et que si on veut parler je
dirais d'avancer de la décentralisation
c'est vers cette perspective qu'il faut
aller parce que c'est comme ça qu'on
fait de la différenciation et qu'on
construit pas un droit un droit des
exceptions et que finalement la commune
nouvelle c'est pas la passion triste on
veut tout encadrer la commune nouvelle
pour reprendre une vieille catégorie
philosophique c'est la passion joyeuse
celle de la on a un cadre et à
l'intérieur de scan les élus locaux vous
évoluez et à cet égard je me permettrai
de faire une suggestion puisque le
président l'isnard évoqué qu'en 1907
finalement le thème fédérateur la raison
sociale de l'association des maires de
France c'était de défendre les libertés
locales je fais une suggestion peut-être
faudrait-il dire aujourd'hui en 2022 à
l'occasion de la deuxième c'est ouf
substituée au terme défendre le terme
étendre c'est-à-dire plutôt que contre
se poser pour ça peut paraître un petit
changement mais c'est toute une autre
philosophie de l'action publique qui en
découle deuxième point la question
l'intercommunalité moi j'aime bien les
choses concrètes et je sais qu'il y a
des scientifiques dans cette salle je me
regarde notamment Joël balandro moi je
suis pas du tout scientifique j'étais
nul en physique je comprenais rien non
non mais par contre il y a une chose que
j'ai retenu une chose que j'ai retenu
c'est quand vous prenez un contenant
vous prenez un contenant
et que ce contenant voulait faire
rentrer un litre d'eau contenant
identique un litre d'eau ou par exemple
un litre de glace ou un kilo de plumes
en fait ça marche pas et en réalité le
problème qu'on a avec l'intercommité
l'intercommité que dis-je les structures
intercommunales c'est exactement ce
problème que les physiciens ont résolu
depuis qu'on fait pas tout rentrer dans
le même contenant ce qui veut dire quoi
ce qui veut dire que le problème de fond
c'est absolument pas l'intercommunalité
c'est absolument elle est absolument
nécessaire pour dépasser un certain
nombre de limites qu'on peut rencontrer
avec notre organisation communale elle a
absolument nécessaire mais le problème
de fond c'est la confusion d'avoir
réduit l'intercommunalité au seul
établissements publics de coopération
intercommunale alors même que la commune
nouvelle notamment dans sa dimension
commune communauté est une
intercommunalité
l'intercommité la plus parfaite puisque
tout est mis en commun et que la commune
communauté permettez-moi là aussi de
vous le dire c'est que certes elle
n'existe pas juridiquement mais il
existe des facto puisque je rappelle
quand même qu'il y a 30 EPCI à fiscalité
propre créé avant la loi éponyme de
Françoise en 2019 qui ont qui sont créés
sous forme de communes communautés
puisque la commune nouvelle a été créée
sur l'intégralité du périmètre de la
structure intercommunale alors si on
veut sortir de du problème qu'on
rencontre de cette confusion et ça je
pense que c'est un débat important de
sortir de cette confusion entre
l'intercommunalité et les structures
comment on peut s'y prendre il faut s'y
prendre en essayant de raisonner sur les
difficultés qu'on rencontre avec les
EPCI actuels et là encore allons vivre
du sujet
alors forcément en peu de temps c'est un
peu généralisant et après il y a des
situations particulières mais les
périmètre sur lesquels on est ils sont
soit
trop vastes quand on veut mettre en
place de la réactivité soit trop
restreint quand on veut aborder des
problématiques telles que le changement
climatique et excusez moi de vous le
dire mais le changement climatique c'est
pas une chimère c'est pas une chimère le
changement climatique c'est absolument
essentiel je dirais qu'on mette en place
des politiques là dessus alors je prends
le changement climatique je pourrais
associer les mobilités et tout pour
démontrer qu'en fait ces périmètres sont
soit trop vases soit trop restre et donc
ça veut dire que la proposition c'est la
suivante c'est de dire il faut qu'à
commune nouvelle monsieur Pélissard je
suis le dire devant vous il faut qu'on
mette en place le régime de
l'intercommunalité nouvelle pour des
intercommunalités fortes et vivantes et
qu'est-ce que c'est l'intercommunalité
nouvelle c'est en fait de revenir à la
base de ce que c'est l'intercommunalité
c'est-à-dire de porter des politiques
structurantes je pense ou mobilité je
pense au développement économique je
pense au logement je pense au changement
climatique je pense aux politiques
environnementales et que tout le reste
relève de l'échelon communale tout le
reste relève de l'échelons communales et
que c'était son communale il peut
s'organiser comme il veut soit il
s'organise sous la forme telle qu'on le
connaît aujourd'hui des communes qui
adhèrent à des OPCI à fiscalité propre
qui eux-mêmes adhèrent à cette
intercommunalité nouvelle qui est
beaucoup plus vaste que l'intercommunité
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui soit il
s'organise sous forme de communes
nouvelles voire de communes communautés
mais si on veut avoir des communes
communautés il s'agit pas de détricoter
les intercommunalités actuels c'est pas
le sujet le sujet c'est de revenir aux
intercommunités qui étaient nos bassins
de vie
elles existaient ces intercoolités et
ces intercommunalités c'était quoi leur
périmètre c'était les périmètres qui
existaient avant le schéma départemental
de la coopération intercommunale de 2016
dernier point troisième point après la
liberté après l'intercommunité la
question des finances
il y a Pierre Bourdieu qui dit qui
disait la chose suivante alors Bourdieu
on aime on n'aime pas je j'ai un ami
sénateur dans cette salle qui dit
Bourdieu mais qui n'aime pas Bourdieu
mais par taquinerie pour lui
qui disait la chose suivante quand le
monde
va pour soi il va de soi ça peut sembler
très étrange mais ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que
en fait ce qui apparaît comme naturel
ne satisfait que ceux à qui cela
convient d'établir cette naturalité et
en fait je veux parler la question du
rapport de l'État et des finances
locales en terme c'est de ça dont je
parlais dire que le système vu de l'état
peut convenir sauf que nous au niveau
des communes nouvelles ça convient pas
du tout
premièrement quand j'entends dire que
les communes nouvelles sur une recherche
de dotation excusez-moi de vous dire
enfin faudrait pas faire porter aux
communes nouvelles un processus
d'encouragement qui a servi de
catalyseur aussi pour l'intercommunité
rien de sous le soleil je vois pas où
elle problème de faire un problème qui
puisse y avoir des encouragements à
porter aux communes nouvelles mais en
réalité les problèmes
les deux problèmes auxquels nous sommes
confrontés sont les suivants de façon
très synthétique première proposition on
ne peut on ne peut pas pouvoir relancer
enfin relancer ou obtenir un deuxième
souffle des communes nouvelles lorsque
on a un régime aujourd'hui qui conduit à
perdre de l'argent j'ai pas besoin de
faire de la commune nouvelle pour savoir
que si j'ai envie de faire quelque chose
mais on me dit dès le début tu vas
perdre de l'argent
en nous de les communes nouvelles il
faut toujours les ramener à des choses
simples il y a personne qui va vouloir
dire
qui va le faire c'est à dire que si il y
a quelqu'un tu perd de l'argent il va
pas le faire donc ça veut dire que un
minima il faut absolument je dirais
inscrire dans la loi et pas par un tweet
mais inscrire par voie d'amendement
que
le quand on pour les communes nouvelles
on doit avoir un minima le garanti le
montant des dotations qu'elle perçoivent
la deuxième chose
c'est qu'il faudrait qu'il est à une
pensée des dotations sur les communes
nouvelles je sais pas si vous êtes
penché sur la loi de finances de l'année
dernière qui propose de sortir la
dotation de solidarité urbaine pour les
communes nouvelles j'y peux rien si
l'État a subi et n'a pas
anticipé ce qu'elle est ta commune
nouvelle c'est-à-dire qu'effectivement
il y a des communes nouvelles qui
aujourd'hui bénéficient de la déesse
alors qu'elles sont composées de
communes majoritairement qui font 2 3000
habitants dont aucune n'était éligible à
la déçu et que la constitution de la
commune nouvelle les rend éligibles et
qu'effectivement quand on remonte à ce
qui était la déçu je vous rappelle
c'était les émeuts de Vaulx-en-Velin en
1991 on est quand même très très loin
dans les communes nouvelles et je pense
à certains le visage que je regarde mais
quand même très très loin des émeutes de
Vaulx-en-Velin sauf que la péréquation
elle s'adresse à tout le monde et que
c'est commune là on en bénéficié alors
si on veut sortir de ce régime de
dotation c'est très simple c'est très
simple en fait plus on complique suffit
mais on veut résoudre les problèmes
pour résoudre le problème des dotations
pour les communes nouvelles existantes
il faut leur maintenir les deux le
montant des dotations dont elle
bénéficier jusqu'à présent il n'y a pas
de raison avec la loi de finance l'année
dernière de leur faire perdre de
l'argent comme c'est le cas il vous
verrez dans le rapport les montants ça
se chiffre quand même en dizaines de
dizaines de millions d'euros la deuxième
chose c'est que si on veut développer
les communes nouvelles pour les
nouvelles enfin celles qui viendrait
être créée maintenant plutôt que de
calculer le montant des dotations sur la
population totale de la commune nouvelle
c'est de calculer les dotations sur
chacune des communes déléguées et c'est
là où ça rejoint le débat sur les mers
délégués tout et ça on n'a pas le temps
de le développer ici mais c'est
absolument essentiel c'est à dire que
quand vous faites tous les calculs et de
vous calculez vos dotations sur les
communes déléguées il y aura plus
d'effets d'aubaine
d'une commune nouvelle qui de par sa
taille serait éligible à des dotations
alors qu'aucune de ces communes
fondatrices n'était éligibles il y aura
plus d'effet d'aubaines et puis dernier
point on pourrait y rajouter un
encouragement comme je dirais comme les
l'intercommités a pu en bénéfice alors
pourquoi conclure pour conclure parce
que sinon je vais trop long
en fait j'ai commencé par les
hachoirs vous expliquant qu'il fallait
pas raisonner par esprit de
symétrisation en fait je vais terminer
par les premières paroles d'une chanson
rassurez-vous je vais pas la chanter je
vous dirai pas de petite c'est je vous
donne simplement une date c'est qu'elle
a été écrite et chantée pour la première
fois par une artiste très connue
française en 1999
et qui disait la chose suivante pour me
comprendre il faut savoir qui je suis
pour me comprendre il faut comprendre ma
vie et pour la prendre devenir mon ami
et ben je trouve que ça colle très bien
pour les communes nouvelles et j'espère
que ce rapport que vous lirez et cette
présentation ne pas avoir trahi les
communes nouvelles et Cher Monsieur
Pélissard avoir pu affirmer
l'amitié que je vous porte et l'oeuvre
révolutionnaire permet de connaître de
nouvelles perspectives je vous remercie
merci
[Applaudissements]
je vous propose qu'on enchaîne tout de
suite sur les sur les différents
témoignages qui vont émailler cette
deuxième séance on va commencer
justement avec Joël balandro vous avez
été cité au titre de vos
scientifique
et bien maintenant vous allez nous
parler en tant que mère devront donc
trois communes 8800 habitants créés
2019 vous allez revenir aussi sur ces
questions financières il a été dit que
aujourd'hui créer une commune nouvelle
ça peut vouloir dire se retrouver avec
moins d'argent qu'on en avait la veille
c'est quand même un problème
exactement je vais je vais illustrer les
propos de sciences politiques de
Monsieur Aubel puisqu'il fait de la
science mais elle est molle alors le
sujet le sujet communautaire et et
commune nouvelle il est il est
extrêmement important parce que la la
commune nouvelle c'est souvent le un
replacement dans le cadre intercommunal
de de la commune d'origine ou des
communes d'origine alors politiquement
je sais pas le sujet que je vais aborder
là mais on le sait tous
financièrement et plutôt même en termes
de compétences et l'enjeu il est majeur
et ça rejoint l'interpellation de
Vincent Aubel sur la ce que réaliser une
intercommunalité avant 2015 est-ce que
réalise les nouvelles intercommunalités
aujourd'hui et comment sont considérés
dans ce cadre-là les relations des
communes et des interco ça a du sens
parce que effectivement certains pour
répondre au fait que une ancienne
interco dans le nord des cohérents
puisque c'est je vais l'illustrer par
les propos nous on a fusionné en 2013
pour faire des des interco nouvelles de
la Communauté de Communes des coévrons
en Mayenne et dans ce cadre là on a
chacun voulu les anciennes intercours
garder localement les compétences
qu'elles avaient etc ce qui était pas
possible puisque la nouvelle interco
prend des compléments intercommunales et
les communes récupère des compétences
communales les mêmes certains pour
résoudre le problème c'est dit ce serait
bien que y ait quatre communes nouvelles
qui portent les quatre anciennes interco
qui soit qui la représentent et puis que
demain on on avance sur ce schéma là ça
a pas pu être fait pour des raisons
politiques
longtemps ça aurait été effectivement
une solution parce qu'aujourd'hui la
nouvelle interco ne veut pas porter
certains équipements qui dépendent des
anciennes interco puisque c'est pas de
même niveau c'est pas du même intérêt et
on est en train de rendre des
équipements ou des des structures de
loisirs à des communes à des communes
qui avant le porter au niveau
intercommunal de plus petite taille donc
par exemple le plan d'eau le gymnase qui
avait une une importance intercommunale
quand on était à B 4500 habitants enfin
4500 habitants pour la communauté de
communes de B 2000 pour la communauté
actuelle et demain vous lui rendez par
contre son équipement la commune de B
est un tout petit son intérêt serait
peut-être et sûrement au niveau de sa de
son bassin de vie de son ancien
intercommunité de faire comme une
nouvelle ce serait son intérêt propre de
même que peut-être que sur le everon où
je suis comme une nouvelle 8800
habitants il serait peut-être pertinent
que je me pose la question et on se les
poser pour le coup et vous allez voir la
réponse elle est financière et elle
touche tout de suite un problème 88 ans
mon bassin de vie les 12000
je passe un cap et là même on allait
voir gentiment mes voisins je leur dis
non non je ne passerai pas les 10000
habitants on a fait nos calculs
financiers fiscaux etc et on se retrouve
à plus de 10000 à perdre sur les trois
années qui passent les trois années de
stabilisation on repère le million qu'on
a gagné avant et après on le perd tous
les ans enfin on perd la suite tous les
ans ces sommes là donc la question de la
commune communauté se pose complètement
en termes des nouvelles compétences
exercées par les communes de ce que les
maires les élus locaux veulent faire de
leurs compétences communales comment ils
veulent l'exercer ou pas et comme ils
veulent plutôt en exercer de ne pas en
exercer et effectivement la question de
la taille critique se pose d'autant plus
si les communes sont noyées dans des
grandes intercos dans lesquelles il
n'exerce plus de responsabilités donc
voilà il y a un vrai sens à aller vers
des choses
on va dire différentes on peut alors en
subsidiarité en responsabilité on parle
bien des compétences que les communes
veulent prendre et dans ces cas-là
quelle est la taille critique pour les
prendre la question financière se pose
alors on passe alors pour le coup
Vincent a
a dit les mots de David Lisnard donc je
le félicite donc j'aurais pas les
répéter et sur les dotations à maintenir
pour chacun dire qu'on a toujours des
centralités on a toujours autant de
voirie communale on a toujours autant de
d'église on a toujours autant de salle
des fêtes on a autant de charges fixe
comme on dit en entreprise qui ne sont
pas diluées dans dans la commune
nouvelle même si on fait d'autres
économies d'échelle le point où que je
soumets à la à votre sagacité et à votre
vigilance c'est que les commissions de
terre les fonds de péréquations les
amandes de police les il existe tout un
tas de micro dotations répartis à la au
libre à la libre administration des des
conseils départementaux des des
préfectures des conseils régionaux ou à
nouveau on parle de la commune
de quelle commune parle-t-on parle-t-on
de la commune déléguée par le ton de la
commune administrative et pour des
raisons on va dire de d'économie larvée
et de façon de ne pas exploser ces
budgets on va considérer une commune
pour une commune administrative et fait
pervers de cela on se partage une
enveloppe de sang entre 25 communes
demain on sera on se repartage et nos
lobe de centre 20 commune
bah les disques ont bougé ont eu tort
puisque puisque vous vous trouvez à
répartir une enveloppe entre des
communes et non pas entre des fonctions
des services etc donc celui qui ne bouge
pas à la fin celui qui l'a fait preuve
d'aucune solidarité mais comme dans tous
les systèmes solidaire celui qui ne
bouge pas et s'il est peu nombreux à la
fin il est toujours gagnant
dans tous les systèmes solidaires si
personne ne bouge on est tous perdants
et donc donc voilà donc la communauté la
commune nouvelle c'est ça c'est cette
solidarité etc et dans les dans les
moments financiers enfin j'en sais
répartition là il faudrait y faire
attention donc voilà nous on a eu ce
frein j'en avais proposé des amendements
au Sénat et ils ont été refusés non pas
par le Sénat parce que Madame Gatel les
a porté avec brio et mais pour mais ça
va point marché ça n'a pas marché mon
garçon mais elle dit en rentrant en
Ille-et-Vilaine et on s'arrêtant sur la
route en Mayenne et et donc voilà l'état
n'a pas donné suite à ces demandes là
mais c'est très important si on veut
continuer à évoluer alors je dis
toujours en liberté mais en capacité
quoi non donc faut le faire comme ça je
vais pas être plus long merci Monsieur
balandro votre voisine Laurence Perez
donc vous vous êtes maire d'une des
rares comme une nouvelle qui s'est créée
très récemment puisque c'est une commune
Noël qui a été créée le 1er janvier 2022
dans la Drôme
saint-jean-de-galaure donc deux communes
qui ont fusionné 1300 habitants
quel est votre premier retour
d'expérience vous n'avez que 9 mois
d'existence en tant que commune nouvelle
et quel bilan tirez-vous de
l'accompagnement ou pas d'ailleurs des
services de l'État
pendant le début de cette aventure alors
déjà bonjour et merci de cette
invitation effectivement on a une
commune nouvelle très récente pour
autant en Ami 6 ans à la créer donc le
retour d'expérience il va être un peu
plus long que les 9 mois qu'on viennent
de vivre ensemble puisque
c'est au niveau de ce qu'on attendait
c'est à dire que c'est pour l'instant
une très belle réussite en termes
d'appropriation de la population même si
voilà vous l'avez dit aussi on est deux
petites communes même s'il y a beaucoup
plus petit encore dans la Drôme on est
sur un territoire où c'est pas très à la
mode de faire des communes nouvelles
donc ça aussi c'est un peu plus
compliqué à s'approprier tout ça au
niveau des élus et de notre
environnement plus général
mais voilà notre histoire a commencé il
y a 6 ans on est parti à trois communes
à la demande d'une plus petite commune
encore qui avait 160 habitants
et qui nous a quitté en route donc on
est resté les deux autres communes on a
travaillé ensemble on vit déjà beaucoup
ensemble quand je dis on a travaillé
c'est ça fait partie aussi des lacunes
et du non accompagnement à notre niveau
l'État c'est que des petites communes on
a pas les services dont vous parliez
tout à l'heure on a des petits services
on a discrétaire numérique on n'a pas de
DGS et on n'a pas les moyens de prendre
des bureaux d'études et de faire du
marketing etc donc tout ça c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué ça demande
beaucoup plus d'engagement de la part
des élus pour autant se passionant on
croyait beaucoup à ce projet on disait
souvent que on voulait faire ensemble ce
qu'on n'aurait pas pu faire seul et
c'est une réalité aujourd'hui quand je
dis on le vit bien ce qui a été plus
compliqué c'est le nom ça aussi ça a été
évoqué le nom ça a été très compliqué
même si au départ nous on s'est dit
enfin sachant que ça serait compliqué
parce que c'est la première question
qu'on nous posait on se dit on verra
plus tard on construit on le fera à la
fin on la fait à la fin avec la
population alors à notre façon en
mettant des questionnaire dans toutes
les boîtes aux lettres en disant
proposer nous des noms on a récupéré
tout ça on a refait un dernier sondage
en disant on retient quatre noms lequel
vous choisissez et les critères que les
deux conseils municipaux avaient mis
étaient entre autres on veut pas accoler
nos deux noms nos ex de noms ni dans un
sens ni dans l'autre parce que ça
mettait une des deux communes en avant
et on voulait pas absorber la deuxième
commune plus petite en gardant que le
nom de la plus grosse aussi
donc on a gardé de l'histoire donc la
construction de ce nouveau nom c'est
aussi voilà ça prend par contre notre
territoire notre territoire pardon et
l'histoire de nos deux communes
on a une pétition sur le nom par exemple
c'était notre seule difficulté c'était
pas sur la création de la commune
nouvelle mais sur le nom
et on s'est aperçu qu'en fait c'était
pas la nouvelle le problème donc
finalement c'est dit le nom on va
continuer je dis effectivement souvent
le temps nous donnera raison parce que
dans le non ce qui était important c'est
que les deux ex non de communes
historique allait rester et en fait le
temps nous donner raison puisque il y a
toujours une église à la mode de Galore
il y a toujours une église à muraille il
y a toujours une école à la mode de gala
il y a toujours une école à muraille et
nos deux villages n'ont pas été gommés
de la carte ils existent toujours il y a
une entité territoriale qui est nouvelle
et un outil que nous a pris comme outil
de d'aménagement de notre petit
territoire mais pour lui donner du sens
effectivement je pense qu'on a pas à
avoir sur nos petites communes une salle
des fêtes par commune un terrain de foot
par commune et qu'aujourd'hui les
habitants sont contents de voir que ben
nous on a un gymnase par exemple sur
notre ex commune
fondatrice et que les habitants de la
commune d'à côté maintenant donc qui
font partie de la même comme une
nouvelle ils ont accès
pour des locations week-end etc et que
dans l'autre sens on a des airs de
loisirs qu'on n'avait pas sur ma commune
historique donc voilà pourquoi
l'appropriation c'est bien fait par
contre à notre niveau si on doit évoquer
les difficultés elles sont pratiquées ce
qui a été très compliqué pour nous c'est
toute la partie administrative en amont
alors c'est bien de nous faire une liste
et de nous dire faut prendre une des
livres il faut faire une charte on a
fait tout ça et on a réussi à faire
prendre la mayonnaise au niveau des élus
parce que voilà c'est on a appris à se
connaître etc mais la difficulté elle
est sur
la délibération et puis tout ce qui va
avec derrière tous les contrats qu'on
doit revoir tous les marchés publics sur
lesquels on doit faire des avenants tous
les documents toute la coordination
qu'on doit faire de la préfecture qui ne
nous soutient pas beaucoup qui nous a
pas soutenu beaucoup et j'irai même
jusqu'au bout du bout du de du côté
pratique au pratique et de
l'appropriation par nos habitants c'est
même aujourd'hui 9 mois après je vais
vous donner un exemple très concret je
viens de changer mon véhicule j'ai fait
bien remplir mes papiers pour la carte
grise et qu'elles sont au nombre de
saint-jean-de-galant et j'ai reçu deux
courriers le premier courrier de la
préfecture qui me fait même pas qui ne
mentionne même pas saint-jean-de-galant
je suis encore à 26 240 la mode de
galant et ma carte grise qui marque
saint-jean-de-galaure comme un nom de
communistorique et 26240 la mode de
galant alors que ça devrait être
l'inverse donc voilà ce qui est
différent pour nos administrés quand on
leur demande de changer leurs papiers au
fur et à mesure c'est que ce code
n'existe pas sur la plupart des sites
mais je parle des sites institutionnels
parce que je vous garantis que
malheureusement Amazon et les autres ils
ont vite pris le pli par contre voilà
l'institution est très très lente et ça
pour nos habitants en termes
d'appropriation c'est compliqué parce
qu'ils disent ouais vous dites
Saint-Jean mais ça n'existe pas voilà
donc en termes pratiques ou pratiques il
manque ce soutien en tant que nous élu
et services on a encore une fois pas de
gros moyens on n'a pas le soutien
financier qui fait qu'on pourrait se
payer c'est bureaux d'études et on n'a
pas le soutien ou pas assez en tout cas
de de l'administration je voudrais juste
rajouter que par contre j'ai eu un
énorme soutien de Julie Roussel donc je
voulais juste la citer et de l'AMF en
général mais en termes de conseillère
technique elle a vraiment joué son
boulot pour des petites communes pour
comme nous c'était hyper précieux voilà
merci merci pour elle
on va finir ce tour de table en Corrèze
avec Jean-Jacques Dumas donc maire de
saint-thibard 680 habitants combien de
communes fusionnées
alors je ne sais pas si je suis
parfaitement adapté pour intervenir ce
matin puisque nous avons essayé de faire
une commune nouvelle des 2015 à trois
communes pour faire une commune
d'environ 1400 habitants et puis ça
échoué au dernier moment parce qu'un
maire c'est désolidarisé et nous sommes
en train de relancer le processus
il n'en demeure pas moins je veux
rassurer Jacques Pélissard je demeure un
ambassadeur convaincu et passionné et je
remercie encore Jacques Pélissard pour
cette loi que je trouve formidable parce
que il a réussi dans cette loi 2015 à
concilier la création d'une commune plus
adaptée à nos temps tout en ne rayant
pas d'un trait de plume l'histoire
comment les communes déléguées et
là-dessus je voudrais revenir sur le
débat qui a eu un petit peu ce matin sur
les mers délégués je crois que dans les
territoires très ruraux le maire délégué
est important il peut continuer à faire
sa cérémonie au monument aux morts à
faire les quelques mariages qui a et où
les gens sont encore attachés à la
communion historique on ne sait pas pour
combien de temps mais la commune des et
le maire délégué sont une excellente
idée
alors depuis 2015 je m'interroge je
m'interroge parce que avec une loi aussi
prometteuse que celle là aussi bien fait
je suis étonné qu'il n'y ait pas eu
davantage de création de communes
nouvelles parce qu'on s'aperçoit bien
quand on regarde un peu la carte des
communes nouvelles
que elles se sont concentrées dans
quelques territoires dans quelques
départements et d'ailleurs la plupart
des intervenants de ce matin sont dans
ces départements où il s'est créé des
communes de grandes tailles
des communes nouvelles de grande taille
avec plusieurs communes et si vous
voulez nous
dans les territoires hyper ruraux il
s’est créé très peu de communes
nouvelles quand on regarde le nombre de
communes nouvelles créées par
département c'est 2 3 4 5 6
un maximum et souvent de deux communes
maximum trois communes tous ces
départements de
la diagonale du vide ces départements où
monsieur le Président de la République
pour les revitaliser veut mettre les
migrants et donc je pense que dans ces
départements là
la création de commune nouvelle
ce n'est pas une histoire d'avoir de
grands projets j'entends bien tous ceux
qui disent la commune nouvelle se crée
autour d'un projet autour d'une d'un
désir de travailler ensemble je dis que
dans ces départements là
la commune nouvelle
et la véritable survie de la commune
si je prends l'exemple de mon
département la Corrèze
nous avons presque sans commune de moins
de 200 habitants
plus de 30 communes de moins de 100
habitants
comment voulez-vous que ces communes qui
n'ont plus d'écoles qui n'ont plus de
commerce qui n'ont qui ont une mairie
ouverte deux demi-journées par semaine
comment voulez-vous qui ont des
difficultés à trouver des élus
des conseillers municipaux nombre de
conseillers municipaux nécessaires c'est
une première chose mais des mères même
il faut solliciter et resolicité pour
trouver des mers en Corrèze nous avions
aux dernières élections au premier tour
un certain nombre de communes qui
n'avaient pas de candidats il y en a eu
au deuxième tour parce que tout le monde
s'en est occupé les sous-préfets mais
c'est quand même une inquiétude donc il
est indispensable de créer des communes
nouvelles
alors moi je suis d'accord sur le fait
qu'on ne peut pas créer par obligation
ni parfait des cartes des communes comme
ça pourrait être envisagé
mais on peut inciter alors les
incitations sont de deux ordres
il y a des incitations qui ne coûte rien
parce que aujourd'hui
les préfets n'ont rien fait
pour
pousser un peu les mers dans les zones
difficiles à créer des communes
nouvelles vous savez je reprends les
propos du président pélissa en 2013 on
lui avait dit que par les communes
nouvelles c'était casse-gueule alors les
préfets ils ont complètement compris ça
ça comprend vite et ils ont dit c'est
casse-gueule
peut-être il y a quelques exceptions il
y a quelques exceptions mais la plupart
on touche pas à ça on n'a pas reçu
d'instructions du gouvernement donc
surtout ne nous occupons pas de ça ça ne
peut que créer des ennuis moi je crois
que la première des choses à faire si on
veut créer des communes nouvelles dans
cette territoire là c'est que les
préfets soient un peu incitatifs
lors des eaux vous savez ce serait
peut-être bien regarder les communautés
si vous pouvez faire quelque chose
[Musique]
il y a des choses comme ça puis il y a
des choses simples
qui paraissent idiote mais après le
premier mandat dans l'ordre du tableau
les mers délégués
sont placés après les adjoints ça coûte
rien ça les mers délégués c'est souvent
des
anciens maires
ils doivent être en tête du tableau je
sais pas pourquoi ça a été fait comme ça
on peut même c'est yos que je veux dire
ça va vous faire rigoler mais on peut
même les
mais auront une écharpe en or les
adjoints à argent on peut même trouver
une couleur pour le maire délégué qui
différenciera un petit peu le mer
délégué c'est des détails qui comptent
beaucoup croyez-moi en psychologie les
détails peuvent compter déjà et puis ma
grand-mère disait qu'on faisait pas
d'omelette sans casser deux alors là
c'est vrai on peut pas le gouvernement
ne peut pas se contenter de dire les
territoires ruraux on vous aime bien
les paroles ça suffit pas il faut y
mettre un peu d'argent alors il y a des
choses simples bien sûr en partant
et Monsieur Aubel la bien dit tout à
l'heure en partant
de des DGF qui existaient avant
majorer la DGF majoré la DGF en partant
de celle d'avant en disant ben vous
aurez pendant 10 ans 20% des GF en plus
et après on reviendra au régime normal
progressivement
non mais vous êtes ambitieux je vous
fais rire je suis en train de vouloir
créer des communes ruraux des communes
nouvelles dans les territoires qui en
ont le plus besoin dans ces communes de
toutes petites tailles vous n'y
arriverez pas autrement dans la DETR
vous pouvez bonifier la DETR de 10
points vous pouvez
prioriser l'attribution de la DETR et si
on n'arrive pas à des choses comme ça si
on n'arrive pas à des choses comme ça
c'est
l'existence même de la commune nous
sommes tous ici pour maintenir la
commune comme lien social comme lien de
proximité si on n'arrive pas à vous avez
des territoires entiers je vous donne
mon billet dans 20 ans vous n'aurez plus
de communes
je vous remercie merci Monsieur le Maire
alors il nous reste il nous reste un peu
plus de 20 minutes avant de devoir
mettre fin cette matinée donc je vous
propose qu'on prenne 10 minutes pour
faire un petit temps d'échange
question-Réponses et puis il nous
restera 10 minutes pour les conclusions
de nos présidents est-ce qu'il y a des
questions dans la salle où l'a déjà
plein de maquillettes 10 minutes
question et réponse allez-y ici monsieur
[Musique]
pourquoi parce que construire construire
on le sait c'est l'avenir mais il va y
avoir quelques difficultés aujourd'hui
en France la grosse maladie de la France
c'est que dès qu'il y a des bons élèves
c'est-à-dire qui s'avancent qui essayent
d'évoluer et bien pendant deux trois ans
on les poussins et puis après on leur
tape sur le doigt en disant mais non
vous avez plus droit à ça vous avez plus
droitier et moi ma grande crainte en
tant que commune rurale de 2200
habitants
dans un sur l'Aubrac puisqu'on fait
partie du Parc Naturel Régional Aubrac
on va de 450 à 1200 mètres d'altitude
mais c'est que quand on veut construire
il nous faudra du terrain aujourd'hui on
nous parle de zéro artificialisation si
vous voulez un projet pour construire
des projets il faut l'avenir et croyez
moi je suis fervent défenseur de la
nature je fais de la concertation sur le
thème de la nature
par mon métier voilà donc c'est cette
difficulté deuxième difficulté quand on
grossit et ben aujourd'hui on va se
trouver avec une une commune qui est en
2021 avait une marge brute de 35%
aujourd'hui en 2023 on va se trouver
dans l'impossibilité de payer notre note
électrique on passe de 100.000 euros à 2
millions d'euros
voilà donc c'est ça ça et c'est les
points qu'on a quand même en travers
voilà merci Agnès
oui merci moi je voulais juste pas
intervenir pour pas allonger les débats
et laisser la place au maire mais c'est
vrai que on a entendu ce matin
longuement l'idée d'accompagnement c'est
à dire que il faut que les communes
nouvelles retrouvent dans un second
souffle selon Monsieur Bell moi je
dirais retrouve le vent en tant qu’élu
d'une commune littorale et pour cela il
faudra évidemment que que l'État aussi
s'implique fortement et vous l'avez cité
madame la Présidente tout à l'heure de
la délégation nous sortons demain un
rapport avec notre collègue qui est
rouge sur à la recherche de l'État dans
les territoires et on se rend compte
fortement à vos expériences que
l'accompagnement de l'État a été assez
comment dire en nous de manière
politiquement correcte
faible ou c'est assez en dent de scie
donc moi ce qui m'intéressait dans vos
expériences et retours d'expérience
c'était de savoir justement qui vous
avez aidé dans la création de vos
communes nouvelles est-ce que sur vos
territoires respectif là le préfet le
sous-préfet a été présent à vos côtés ou
rien du tout
est-ce que vous avez
rebondir sur l'intervent dans la
sénatrice il est clair qu'on demande pas
l'état de faire des cartes mais si
l'état nous accompagne pas ça ne
fonctionne pas et là je voulais faire un
sondage peut-être que là où les communes
nouvelles ce sont développées c'est
parce que les préfets ont accompagné
sans forcer la main mais ont accompagné
et ont enlevé quelques obstacles qu'on a
sur notre route
je vais vous donner la parole parmi les
témoins de cette deuxième séquence un
élément de réponse à Madame canaille
Thomas janvier nous on a eu la chance
effectivement d'avoir une préfecture et
une sous-préfecture
voilà qui nous a accompagné qui a été à
l'écoute et je parle tout à l'heure de
la charte de gouvernance c'est
préfecture qu'on a pu la construire donc
voilà nous on est peut-être le contre
exemple je sais pas mais mais c'est vrai
que ça et pour effectivement aller dans
le sens que Lisa la collègue ça rassure
et ça nous donne un cadre et c'est vrai
que c'est beaucoup plus facile quand on
a un accompagnement d'essaye de l'État
parce que les gens ça rassure ça donne
une méthodologie et puis derrière on a
une garantie que la commune nouvelle
sera réussi administrativement et
juridiquement donc ça nous on a eu cette
chance là et Françoise peut témoigner la
préfecture de Bretagne et la souper la
sous-préfecture de Fougères vitré
là-dessus a été a été exemplaire
Christine Blanchet je voulais juste
alors moi j'ai pas souvenir d'un grand
accompagnement du de du sous-préfet mais
par contre ce qu'on connaît en tant que
petite ville de demain on a chargé de
projet alors en effet qui a mi-temps bon
bref mais je pense que ça aurait été
utile de l'ingénierie en fait pour
anticiper ce qu'on a pas anticipé vous
parlez des effets de seuil et de l'air
d'accueil des gens du voyage par exemple
donc nous on a été concerné par ça même
si de toute façon on l'aurait fait parce
qu'on a du passage mais c'est vrai que
c'est ce que les habitants retiennent et
tous ces effets de seuil même sur les
commerces parce que nos commerces ont
perdu des recettes aussi à cause de ça
qu'on n'a pas anticipé ça en fait donc
on a une ingénieur de la même façon que
là on l'a sur petite ville de demain je
pense que ça pourrait
utilement et ça et ça permettra nos DGS
de pas être porteur forcément de de
cette création par rapport à la commune
d'à côté etc aussi
merci Monsieur au fond oui Bob Pascal
becquioly maire de une commune qui
s'appelle perchinocé 2200 habitants je
voulais la poser la question de qui est
un peu pointue sur un mot qui est apparu
il y a quelques temps la diffusion
parce que les préfets font référence à
des articles 22 12 du CGCT jusqu'au
articles suivants et des communes qui se
rendent compte qu'il y avait en commun
une nouvelle peuvent très bien demander
de reprendre une un morceau de
territoire d'une commune nouvelle pour
pouvoir se marier parce que pour se
marier il faut se toucher comme chacun
le sait et elle ne se touche pas donc
elles ont besoin d'une partie d'un
territoire déjà d'une commune nouvelle
donc les articles qui qui résistent la
sortie ou la diffusion ne sont pas du
tout le souhait du législateur et de
Monsieur Pélissard de l'époque donc je
pense qu'il faudrait statuer sur ces
articles là pour que les diffusions ne
puissent pas avoir lieu puisqu'elles
sont régies par une commission gérée par
le préfet c'est pas au préfet de
légiférer ni de arbitrer quelque chose
qui est du libre administration d'une
commune
merci
un commentaire là dessus
sur cette question spécifique juste
Françoise Gatel très rapidement
effectivement
la question que vous soudain à chaque
fois sont des situations un peu
particulières très imbriquée etc donc en
fait le principe de la commune nouvelle
n'intègre pas de possibilités de divorce
on est voilà donc du coup ça suppose
bien qu'il nécessitait de réfléchir en
amont et que c'est il y a quelques
exemples de enfin de diffusion ou de
enfin d'annulation de la commune
nouvelle à ce stade essentiellement
uniquement ma connaissance pour des vis
de forme et de procédure c'est-à-dire
des délibérations qui ont pas été prises
dans l'ordre que sais-je je pense qu'il
faut qu'on aujourd'hui dans le bilan que
fait la MF ça fait partie des choses
qu'on doit regarder est-ce que la
question elle existe beaucoup de quelle
nature elle est voilà
monsieur
oui
bonjour Gérard Daouda mère du mener dans
le en Bretagne je me permets de oui
mais c'est moi et voilà et de fait juste
une question qui m'interrogeait sur ce
que tu disais justement tout à l'heure
c'est les dotations qui
devraient diminuer si j'ai bien compris
suite à une loi qui a été passée l'an
passé
je sais que nous notre DGF a diminue
tous les ans de 20000 euros à peu près
est-ce que c'est cette loi là qui le
permet est-ce qu'on doit s'attendre à
une diminution d'autres dotations
mais ta question pertinente me permet de
le faire honnêtement moi je vous délivre
un message personnel extrêmement
important il faut que vous nous ayez
et que il faut que vous sensibiliser
tous vos députés et tous vos sénateurs
aux effets collatéraux de la création
d'une commune nouvelle qui fait que la
commune au sens juridique elle augmente
de population et elle vous fait basculer
dans des catégories de communes
ordinaire si je puis dire en population
donc vous allez passer en déçu vous
allez perdre de l'argent vous avez des
effets de seuil on l'a vu voilà et qu'à
un moment moi je le dis beaucoup au
Sénat mais mes collègues écoutent bien
mais quand on comprend pas la commune
nouvelle je vous assure que moi j'ai du
mal et je vais vous dire mon point de
vue c'est que en gros on le discours qui
est parfois tenu mais enfin c'est comme
une ça y est c'est comme une nouvelle
donc un moment elle devienne entre
humaines normales bah je dis sauf que
normal la politique de la ville elle ira
jamais dans une commune de 15000
habitants qui est faite de trois
communes l'air des gens du voyage ou les
logements sociaux mais il n'y a pas de
besoin personne va venir habiter bon et
dans une période de raréfaction
des dons de l'État pour être aimable
vous avouez que la générosité la
solidarité elle est difficile
c'est-à-dire chacun et c'est de survivre
donc c'est compliqué donc il faut au
moins qu'on obtienne qu'il n'y ait pas
de perte d'argent ça veut dire que les
effets de seuil alors on les a un peu
bouger mais faut les tenir et que quand
vous êtes une commune nouvelle et si
partout en France on croit la commune
vous n'allez pas détruire l'église du
village de la communion historique parce
que c'est l'identité des gens c'est ça
qui fait commune ou communauté sinon
dans ce pays ça a très bien été sur le
maire à un moment on a déjà eu je crois
sans dix communes où il y a pas eu de
candidose élections les communes elles
sont mortes et les clés des mairies
elles vont être déposées à la préfecture
moi je dis calmement mais il faut qu'on
soit lucide et si un gouvernement il
défend l'idée d'un équilibré de la
vitalité de la ruralité ici nous
sénateurs et députés de nos défendons ça
et bien allons-y donc message personnel
aidez-nous pour qu'on vous aime il faut
que vous alliez parler à chacun de vos
députés de vos sénateurs de ce qu'est la
commune nouvelle sérieusement
monsieur Obel quelques minutes
juste deux secondes juste deux secondes
par rapport à ça le point qui est
soulevé derrière ça ça démontre bien que
la commune déléguée elle est absolument
centrale parce que c'est ce qui fait
qu'une commune nouvelle sinon c'est une
fusion et que moi je ne suggestion parce
que moi j'ai commencé à travailler sur
les questions de seuil j'ai déjà repéré
150 seuils de population qui et qui sont
différentes entre eux et tout et dans
ces cas-là madame la sénatrice madame la
Présidente dans quelle mesure la
délégation collectivité territoriale
plutôt que d'attendre de l'État ne
pourrait passer dire elle-même de cette
étude sur les seuils et de faire une
proposition
la proposition est lancée vous y
répondrez peut-être dans votre
conclusion tout à l'heure
voilà mais nous on est plutôt
proactif et que sur les communes
nouvelles enfin Jacques pélissa et
l'exemple c'est les MF qui a été
proactive je veux l'État ne va pas
spontanément bousculer des choses qui
parfois lui compliquent la vie disons-le
et ça quelque soit le gouvernement nous
on est plutôt allant
alors il y a des questions qui n'ont pas
été prises je redis donc d'abord toutes
les questions qui ont été posées par
écrit elles sont retransmises à l'AMF
qui diffusera ensuite et y compris les
personnes qui sont dans la salle qui ont
pas pu intervenir parce qu'on est pressé
par le temps n'hésitez pas vous n'ira
parler à la fin ou écrire à la MF pour
poser vos questions et être mis en
relation avec les élus qui vous
intéressent
Jean-Marc vase vous nous faites une
petite synthèse de cette deuxième
séquence on a beaucoup parlé du rôle des
préfets et on a beaucoup parlé finances
oui je crois je crois que ce qui a été
dit c'est
ce que Vincent Aubel a dit sur la notion
d'intercommunalité on n'a pas forcément
conçu la commune nouvelle comme un outil
d'intercommunité il n'empêche que tout
de suite se pose la question à chaque
fois
de l'échelle et de la capacité à assumer
des compétences sur un espace pour une
population et dans un comment dire dans
un court historique et cette question là
que vous avez posée à plusieurs reprises
je crois que ce qui a été affirmé c'est
l'indépendance c'est la liberté des élus
de choisir la bonne échelle le bon
périmètre et le bon outil pour répondre
aux missions qui sont les nôtres que la
loi nous donne et
ce travail qui a été fait il s'est il
est venu en quelque sorte être percuté
par le schéma de coopération
intercommunale où on a aussi changé les
échelles des intercos
et forcément à la fois ça a été un
espèce d'effet d'aubaine pour un certain
nombre de se dire dans une grande
interco on a peut-être intérêt à tirer
les premiers et à se regrouper pour
poser dans l'interco
a constaté que l'interco s'éloignait de
la proximité et de la nécessité
d'assumer à ce moment-là dans la
proximité avec un outil adapté j'ai un
exemple dans l'interco dans laquelle je
me trouve où l'interquois conçoit et
gymnase et il y a plus de communes pour
le gérer
personne n'en veut c'est quand même
incroyable parce qu'il y a pas de
commune nouvelle et que le gymnase est
trop important pour la petite commune
qui le reçoit donc ça c'est le premier
élément qui me semble tout à fait
essentiel dans cet esprit de la gestion
de l'espace et des compétences comment
on reconstruit la commune nouvelle
pour faire face finalement à de nouveaux
de nouveaux défis puisque les échelles
ont changé la deuxième chose que qui a
été dites me semble-t-il c'est c'est
autour de l'incitation moi j'ai beaucoup
aimé ce que vous avez dit sur la
question de la survie parce que
finalement c'est ça la question c'est
qu'à un moment ou un autre
si on ne trouve plus d'élus c'est que le
la commune n'existe plus elle n'a plus
l'intérêt il y a plus de désir et donc
en mettant en mouvement parce que c'est
soit on fossilise soit on met en
mouvement et les élus qui prennent
l'initiative de la mise en mouvement
sont en capacité de réécrire un avenir
de construire pas besoin d'avoir
forcément de grands projets mais de
redonner aussi une identité d'avenir à
un territoire qui est en perdition je
pense que ça aussi c'est me semble-t-il
un levier pour convaincre puisque
Jacques Pélissard nous a appelé à être
ambassadeur et avocat donc remettre en
mouvement et puis le troisième point
c'est le rôle de l'État
alors bien sûr j'ai aussi lu le rapport
quand on pense alors on a dit on n'a pas
placé la commission sous la présidence
du préfet on a trouvé mieux on a mis le
président du Département alors bon c'est
pas l'état soit par ce monde qui sont
plus bienveillants avec les
collectivités locales mais c'est pas le
sujet c'est pas un sujet départemental
c'est pas un sujet d'État c'est un sujet
de territoire il me semble-t-il le seul
endroit où on peut encore réfléchir
c'est pas faire un schéma mais qu'on
soit en capacité parce qu'on travaille
tous les jours ensemble c'est le
périmètre intercommunal et de se dire
dans ces grandes intercos comment on
peut reconstruire des territoires qui
soient plus pertinents et comment on
peut donner aux intercos les moyens de
mieux fonctionner
pour répondre aux grands enjeux ça a été
dit de mobilité de réchauffement
climatique de PAC etc et pour aussi
permettre la gestion de la des
compétences de proximité sur les
communes qui sont plus capables de les
faire parce que c'est ça le problème bon
nombre de communes non plus la capacité
de faire je vais vous raconter une
anecdote c'est pas loin de notre
collègue de que new
inauguration d'une école peut-être que
cher ami Agnès y était l'autre jour
4 communes qui ensemble ont décidé de
faire une école ensemble voilà il y a un
civos
et sous préfet qui vient d'arriver
je félicite de l'inauguration enfin tout
le monde coupe le ruban etc puis
Monsieur le Maire mais pourquoi vous
faites pas une commune nouvelle tous les
quatre
[Musique]
faire remonter les sujets
bouger les lois y compris sur les
symboles je crois que là aussi c'est
c'est du devoir de la délégation qui
nous accueille aujourd'hui de nous
écouter de nous faire remonter les
sujets et que vous puissiez dans le
débat parlementaire faire comprendre à
l'exécutif un certain nombre de
nécessité en tout état de cause faut
conclure neutre je conclure ainsi en
toute état de cause la commune nouvelle
n'est pas une commune ordinaire c'est
une commune singulière il faut défendre
cette singularité et à partir de là tous
ceux qui considèrent qu'il faut
supprimer les communes déléguées et ça
peut avoir du sens
bascule en commune ordinaire ils sont
dans le régime de droit commun mais pour
toutes les autres il faut maintenir
cette singularité qui doit nous
permettre bien sûr de de poursuivre le
mouvement et une dernière suggestion
parler de l'étude tout à l'heure je
crois que le panorama de Vincent Aubel
est intéressant il nous faudrait aussi
un panorama
des toutes ces communes qui ne sont pas
allés dans le mouvement pourquoi
comprendre les réticences comprendre les
enjeux de manière à favoriser la comment
dire les incitations qui pourraient
permettre à certains d'y aller il faut
qu'on écoute aussi pourquoi ça s'est pas
fait me semble-t-il merci merci Monsieur
le Maire le côté pour il nous reste deux
ou trois petites minutes donc j'ai
demandé vraiment de mots de conclusion à
Philippe Chalopin d'abord et à Françoise
Gatel très rapidement donc que
ressortez-vous de ces de cette matinée
de travail
très rapidement moi je retiendrai le
titre de notre rencontre c'est à nouveau
souffle et c'est vrai que depuis 2012
il faut vraiment croire à la commune
nouvelle parce que on a quand même
franchi beaucoup d'obstacles tout ce que
vous avez évoqué les problèmes de seuil
les problèmes les démarches avec les
taxes etc nous on a la chance on en joue
d'avoir des des préfets des sous préfets
qui s'intéressaient au sujet je n'ose
pas imaginer là où initie intéresse pas
comment ça peut être compliqué donc il
faut vraiment que l'État cesse enfin moi
il y a une chose qui m'a toujours
interpellé c'est qu'on parlait tout à
l'heure de la loi Marcellin elle était
portée par l'État elle a pas fonctionné
là les communes nouvelles ça pourrait
encore mieux fonctionner mais c'est
porté beaucoup par les élus il faudrait
que l'État effectivement Vienne soutenir
le mouvement et le soutenir il y a
peut-être plusieurs choses à régler le
frein essentiel quand même c'est que
c'est quand même compliqué à vendre une
commune nouvelle pour dire vous vous
allez perdre de l'argent
ça il faut régler le problème parce que
c'est pas encadable c'est pas un
tendable qu'on en gagne pas oui mais
qu'on en perde c'est pas entendable donc
ça c'est un frein que l'État doit
absolument lever et puis que l'État
comprenne que à un moment au lieu de
d'imposer peut-être des cartes etc c'est
peut-être mieux de décrire ces cartes
avec les élus locaux ça sera peut-être
beaucoup plus simple à faire passer si
on veut vraiment décentraliser l'état si
on a vraiment cette volonté et bien il
faut effectivement qu'on s'appuie sur
les communes sur les élus locaux et la
commune nouvelle c'est un exemple très
clair de décentralisation alors tout
fonctionne pas parfaitement partout bien
évidemment mais il y a aussi des
communes entre guillemets historiques où
ça fonctionne pas et la crainte qu'on a
aujourd'hui que moi j'ai c'est que avec
le rapport qui m'a un peu tené parce
qu'on a été auditionné j'avais le
sentiment que en fait il y avait un peu
plus de d'analyses positives c'est
qu'effectivement on décourage ceux qui
veulent s'engager ça c'est le premier
risque donc il faut que l'État prenne de
responsabilité en disant oui on va
travailler avec les territoires oui et
bien on y va et la commune nouvelle ça
peut être ça peut être un exemple on
nous parle d'expérimentation alors on a
dépassé le stade de l'expérimentos mais
ça peut être là quelque chose de
beaucoup à l'échelle nationale ça peut
être important et je suis persuadé pour
reprendre les les propos de notre
collègue Dumas c'est que effectivement
il y a des territoires où il n'y aura
plus de communes
il y a des territoires où il y a des
intercommunalités qui pourront plus
fonctionner parce que les communes
seront absentes de de l'Assemblée
s'impliqueront pas donc un moment donné
c'est la mort des territoires ruraux
mais pas que je pense qu'il faut pas
limiter le débat au territoire ruraux
c'est une problématique de au niveau
national de la place des communes et si
on veut effectivement ne plus avoir de
communes petite grande ou moyenne et
avoir que des intercommunalités qui vont
pas fonctionner parce que pourront pas
te gérer l'interco c'est un très bel
outil mais ça peut pas tout gérer donc
il faut effectivement qu'au niveau de
l'État on nous aide à trouver notre
second souffle en tout cas moi je vous
remercie pour vos interventions parce
que elles étaient toutes extrêmement
enrichissantes merci Madame la fenêtre
Françoise Gatel pour la conclusion
ultime
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais remercier
Franck qui a la difficulté de nous faire
tenir dans le temps donc merci beaucoup
Franck je vous remercie toute l'équipe
de la MF qui fait un travail formidable
d'accompagnement de nos collectivités et
puis dire que je suis profondément
heureuse de cette symbiose entre le
Sénat et la MF sur l'invention
nécessaire pour transformer notre pays
dans un seul but quand on parle
d'efficacité de l'action de X c'est pas
le sort des élus qui est en cause c'est
la confiance dans ce pays la paix
sociale si je puis dire et le fait que
partout dans tous les territoires il y a
quelque part un drapeau qui flotte qui
incarne la République et un maire qui
sera toujours là quel que soit l'heure
et on pourra répondre et non seulement
en temps et je veux saluer les collègues
de la délégation qui ont été nombreux
bien que ce soit un jour de réunion de
commission important ça là juste
quelques mots madame le Maire moi
j'étais très sensible à ce que j'avais
lu ce lundi le temps nous donne raison
et que l'audace les migraines que l'on
peut avoir à conduire ce type de projet
les critiques que l'on prend
il faut
encourager chacun porte et ça parce que
Jacques Pélissard l'a dit Monsieur le
Maire de saint-thiba vous l'avez dit
autrement et ce n'est pas d'oiseaux de
mauvaise augure que de le dire il y va
de ce qui est le cœur de la République
de la pérennité de la survie des
communes et donc la commune nouvelle
pour reprendre un mot qui a un moment
était à la mode désert d'avenir non non
c'est soif de survie parfois et de
survie positive pour permettre qu'on
n'apporte plus à nos territoires donc
l'État doit vraiment nous accompagner
alors un message cher Philippe et
Jean-Marc j'aurais dit à David lisna le
président de la République s'est engagé
à parler assez régulièrement avec la
glisser le message sur le fait que
l'État doit venir accompagner pour des
solutions et puis dernier point
contaminant et contaminé alors
aujourd'hui quand on dit ça se fera tout
le monde mais moi je pense parce qu'ici
nous sommes
un club
d'apôtres de défenseur de gens
courageuses parfait mais maintenant il
faut que ça bouge partout et encore une
fois
allez voir vos députés allez voir vos
sénateurs et des nous et nous nous
serons là faisons bouger les lignes et
vous vous devez transmettre cette
réussite qui est la vôtre pour donner
des idées faire que personne ne soit
seul et encore une fois moi je redis
cette phrase de Lamartine qui m'a
vraiment guidée quand vraiment je me dis
la la dans quel truc on est parti je lis
dans l'avenir la raison du présent si
vous faites ça si vous l'avez fait avec
la difficulté etc c'est parce que vous
étiez un élu soucieux de transmettre
votre commune et de lui donner un avenir
voilà donc vraiment allons-y
merci pour ces mots
[Applaudissements]
merci à tous de votre attention et puis
ben on se dit rendez-vous l'année
prochaine sans doute pour les 8e
rencontre des communes nouvelles au
revoir